at the End of
Time 13
O hey everybody what's going on
hopefully the lightings okay the
camera's okay we haven't moved it so it
should be all right right uh that yeah I
guess it's all right guess all right you
guess it's all right I didn't do
anything different that the right color
yeah all right yeah I didn't change it I
didn't change it I did lower it a little
bit but that's all I did but that and
that was like days and days ago I got my
sexual Tyrannosaur hat on yeah I haven't
worn that in a while I haven't worn this
one in a while somebody said that this
[__] hat was sus this [__] was sus
man that has the
sus I I think he was saying it made me
look gay or Zach does this make me look
gay or it made you look like an actual
sexual predator I don't know what it is
this is [__] this is a damn bush hat
man it's a black one I got I got a black
one I got a black one and I got a damn
tiger stripe
one I can see you do kind of look like
you I'm trying to think of who you
remind me of like wearing that but I
can't think of it you
know make me uncomfortable now take it
out tiet no no no it wasn't anything bad
this one on it wasn't anything bad all
right I was just saying that it's like
it was reminding me of somebody in like
from a movie or like a movie character
but I couldn't think of what and I know
not the one from Predator because I know
that but I couldn't think of the one
that it was reminding me of you know
what I'm saying yeah I spilled glue on
this well that's Gorilla Glue get it'll
come off hey there's weapons and stuff
oh yeah what's going on haven't seen you
in the chat for a while so what's going
on day I was watching him on his channel
yeah he was cuz I just went in there
playing a haunted house game it looked
pretty good or a ghost hunting game oh
what's it called that sounds pretty cool
he can he can say in the comment section
I forgot cuz I like this kind I don't
play a lot it was for the it was for PC
though you could can't get it on Xbox oh
right okay and it started off as a small
game that got bigger and bigger he
didn't really expect it to do anything
but it looked pretty good he running
around going into houses putting up
ghost traps it was what was it called
that sounds
fun
yeah Zach says uh so that movie ruled
I'm assuming you're talking about uh
Killers with flower Moon uh but screw
Regal Theaters for only projecting their
movies at half brightness [__] yeah
that is kind of [__] up they must have
messed that up Zach says I also made the
mistake of getting a seat in the second
front row and had to look up the whole
time my neck hurts so bad we usually sit
um not this well sometimes we sit in the
second R it depends if there's other
[__] there because I like to
sit as far away from other people as
possible possible but um we usually sit
in the row like right behind where the
wheelchair seats are cuz then at least
you know nobody's going to sit in front
of you right weapons and stuff said was
phasmophobia phasmophobia phasmophobia
oh yeah yeah we might have to look into
get I wonder how much is you can't get
it for Xbox well I could play it on you
here if I had time which I don't but
it's just like it sounds fun though oh
and also whoever because I know when we
were talking about like on the movie
thing on Monday night when we were
talking about uh the Batman versus
Dracula and you guys had recommended um
Gotham by Gaslight and um and um the
Doom that came to Gotham we watch both
of those they're great like yeah they
were really really good actually Gotham
by Gaslight was [__] phenomenal I was
I really liked it I think that was the
better out of the two I did too yeah
like the Lovecraft one is cool but like
you said it was almost like it's a
Lovecraft story that happened to have
Batman in it more than like a Batman Man
story that was like had Lovecraft stuff
yeah it was more like a Lovecraft story
it was good it just the T that was the
that was the direction that they wanted
so that was the tone that they they
selected so that's what they got they
gotth them by Gaslight one I was like I
mean I know it's about Jack the Ripper
but I was actually like um really
surprised by how gory it was like how
violent it was yeah you know what I mean
swearing prostitution all kinds of stuff
was in yeah like like [__] blood
flying everywhere and stuff like that I
was like nice yeah that's a great
animated feature yeah I was into it I
was like really good and out of it was
better than it was better than Batman
versus Dracula even though I liked
Batman versus Dracula too but I think
out of the three I thought that was the
best one yeah I think I agree I think
Gotham by gastl was the best one out of
the three that we watched also I finally
finished watching Fall of the House of
Aer like Flanigan series on Netflix last
night I don't know if I'm going to do a
review on it because it seems like such
a Herculean task but it was pretty
[__] great I still like Haunting of
Hill House better but um it was still
pretty awesome it was still pretty
awesome so you know half naked you said
I like the drive-in because I hate
people making noise and chewing well
honestly I think that's the reason
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people are just watching movies at home
now because like I said you get you have
a big TV now you have a soundar and
stuff like that you don't have some like
ched next to you like opening his
popcorn really loud and talking during
the [__] and looking at his phone and
all this other kind of crap like this
all these lights over here in the corner
Jesus Christ
I I I don't understand like why full
grown adults cannot just like sit still
and shut up for two hours it baffles my
mind that they can't do that you know
what I mean I don't know just stay home
and watch the movie if you're going to
do that if you're going to talk dur the
movie then you know I'm not going to a
movie like velocipastor that I want to
like talk all during and like going and
seeing that in the theater and spoiling
everyone else enjoyment of it but
apparently other people are not the same
you know so you know all right so what
we're going to do tonight because it's
not close enough to Halloween to be the
Halloween show cuz Halloween kind of
worked out at on a weird day but I
wanted to put I put like a couple of
kind of more Halloweeny sort of topics
in the poll so this is the one that won
we actually did a show a long time ago
about ghost ships and sea monsters which
was it seemed heavy on the sea monsters
but we talked about some ghost ships and
stuff too but but I wanted to do another
Ghost Ship show cuz I love Ghost Ship
stories so I came up with four new Ghost
Ship stories that we hadn't covered on
the last one so that should be fun all
paranormal run too long no it shouldn't
like they're not super complicated you
know what I mean it's just kind of
like they're not super complicated
stories is all I'm saying but um but
yeah so I think that's what what else uh
have we ever ever seen the movie Ghost
Ship yes I don't remember if we reviewed
it but I've seen it I don't remember if
you've seen it or not no it didn't sound
familiar I saw Death Ship yeah that's a
different yeah we saw Death Ship I think
we covered Death Ship maybe cuz I
remember both of us watching that
together but I've seen Ghost Ship like a
couple of times if you like shock waves
with Peter Cushing you want you want to
see go you want to see Death Ship that's
good too yeah yeah yeah it's about an
old Nazi Ghost Ship intelligence it was
some kind of intelligence ship they were
torturing people on the ship they find
it der like floating out in the ocean
it's haunted as [__] it's haunted as
fuckt and that's pretty [__] haunted
yeah some of the cruise ghosts and in
there and it's it's it's filmed on a
real ship it's pretty interesting his
old [__] der looking ship there what
they filmed the movie on it saw it as a
kid it's back in the 70s I think early
80s sh was creepy as
[__] yeah I think most people probably
confuse it with Ghost Ship but ghost
ship that was was '90s yeah I want to
say that movie was the '90s although the
only part literally and I've seen that
movie like twice but the only part I
remember of ghost ship is that iconic
opening scene where everybody on the
ship gets cut in half by that cord you
know what I mean because that's just so
you can't you do that in the first five
minutes of your movie yeah you're going
to get everyone's attention but then
like the rest of the movie can't like
live up to that I think that was my main
criticism of it but it's like it's a fun
movie otherwise though I know y'all want
to see me get Peg and [__] that might
where did that come from that might
happen
oh man I went to the [__] VA man yeah
he had a doctor's appointment on my day
yeah I took a [__] blood test one of
the one of the blood tests was for uh to
check for prostate cancer and it the PSA
numbers were a little bit elevated since
the last like two years ago that I did
it she wants me she wants me to do those
to do that test again to see if that
number is real it's only four that's not
that bad it was two before that and and
evid between like two and 10 is supposed
to be okay
but she's like well I want to take that
test again you know just in case I might
have to give you a biopsy and I said
biopsy I went and [__] Googled that
[__] that involves sticking a rod up
your ass with a needle on it yeah
[__] stabbing that got get they got
to get the sample somehow if that [__]
comes up you're GNA well I guess I'm
dying of
cancer guess I'm dying of cancer that
how long do I have to live that is how
committed to his to his insistence on
being pegged is he will not even get a
biops not going to let that damn
doctor well you want me to come to the
office and didn't trust you that thing
either man I saw the [__] drawings a
[__] cutaway section of [__] that
dude a cutaway drawing of that dude on
his ass on a table his [__] legs up
in the air like he's in stirups or
something and they stick that Rod that
doesn't not not for me man it looks like
I'm dying of cancer [__] no and it's got
a and then there's [__] St and when
they will stab it in several locations
to make sure that we're going we're
going to get a sample out of the whole
thing and I'm like no no I'm good I'm
dying of cancer I mean I well in a way
like I kind of feel you on that like you
know I'm I'm a woman so we had to go get
like you grew up with that [__] people
like sticking stuff up your snatch like
every year and stuff like that which you
know that wasn't fun either but um you
know and the the thing about Camp guy
says don't have a biopsy I've had one
before he's like my SE was blood red
dark for two or three weeks yeah holy
crap yeah I'm just yeah Zach says put me
to sleep if you got to do that [__] good
God and here's the thing man [__]
those numbers aren't bad she's just
scaring me man she scaring me because
she knows that I'm on HRT she didn't
like that she didn't like that maybe I'm
pretty sure she didn't like that
although Tom also speculated that maybe
she had a crush on him and wanted him
wanted him to keep coming back could be
too yeah she's about the right age she's
about the right age what age is she
about 40 45 is about the right age to
have a crush on me she she looked she's
kind of thirsty she looked okay too yeah
she and she just kept asking too many
goddamn invasive questions and [__] and
you well we're just going to have to
look at that penis huh yeah and I'm
going like this chick might be some kind
of sexual status or something and like
sounding yeah I'm like fing I'm gonna
bring my wife with me next
time see what she thinks of you you know
what I mean and the video camera if this
shit's going to happen I'm going to make
money off well I was just going to say
like if you are somehow like convinced
to do it like at least film it so we can
like make some money and look they did
that biopsy and it came back negative
didn't it because she's just trying to
[__] with me that that that PSA of four
that shouldn't be bad enough I I
researched that
[__] and then it said and I looked at
all the studies they said [__] HRT
and [__] like that should have nothing
to do with PSA numbers and that should
have no that should have no um impact on
uh any kind of prostate thing it's just
just not it's just not a factor that's
old thinking man that's old fashion
thinking they're like back in the damn
they're like back in the [__] tokoma
age they're they're doing the
Inquisition okay they're trying to get
me to convert I mean she's really not
cuz Tom is convinced that all women on
earth want a peg a dude yeah I know too
many man we were at the bar [__] and
and and [__] and and and and and
Melissa was there and I [__] brought
that up she like what's the problem with
that what's wrong with that and I was
just like and then her her boyfriend was
like yeah that's right [__] that bab so
I was going like she's doing the same
[__] thing she's trying to [__] so
now he thinks that all that all women
are like which maybe they do I don't
know but it's I can't speak for
everybody but I'm just saying say ain't
no fixation at the it's some kind of
[__] quest for vengeance or something
man cruel streak and it's not I don't
think well it might trying to deflower
these men it might be cruelty but I
think what it is I don't I don't think
it's I don't know if I'd go so far as
call it Vengeance but I think it's like
you want men to have like a taste of
what you put up with like you know what
you up with it yeah well no I'm just
saying like what you know what I mean
it's just kind of like being penetrated
yeah okay like so you're just like well
now you know what it's like you know
what I'm saying men do man they're
called hyenas the female hyena pegs the
[__] out of the males she got time is
fascinated by the whole hyena thing cuz
she's got her her dick is the same size
as a male hen I think it's bigger maybe
bigger and and they're dominant they
they're dominant over the [__] that's
pretty cool I like that yeah evidently
the males are all cool they're like man
these [__] them [__] are crazy fck
you you can make you can make a pet out
of a male hyena not a female please save
me yeah they're like I can't understand
it I'm nice to her keep jumping on her
back and putting that [__] up
in it's insane hypothetical hyena
conversation this is what you come to
13:00 said dude I feel you I feel
[__] you know they try they you know
you guys are paying for what we're doing
I understand man [__] you guys
getting a shitty end of this
stick getting stuff crammed up EV no
evidently the male highers are cool they
but the female high you can't [__] with
them their testosterone levels are super
[__] high right Zach says if it was
Vengeance for women the why a gay guys
do butt stuff I mean it's that like I
said it's not a perfect Theory I'm just
saying that I'm not saying that they're
different they're different women are
different well no I'm just saying that
um I don't know like if other if like
women that want to Peg men like have
that but it's just kind of like I could
see that maybe that was like an aspect
of it perhaps I just got a feeling I got
a feeling that uh between the dudes it's
different than it is between the [__]
yeah it's I don't think the dynamic is
quite the same
no well like I said in the dynamic like
I said I'm not going to speak for
everybody because everybody's different
so you know what I mean I'm just saying
that that might be that's kind of just
where my head went to yeah I'm just
still trying to think of how I'm going
to deal with this
doctor yeah he's been like ranting about
it since he got home I've been mad about
yeah he's mad about it like we drove
down to the liquor store and he's just
like just ranting about it whole SE I've
seen the numbers my numbers fall fall
within pretty good range you know so she
G to have to convince me and she's going
to take an awful lot of convincing I got
the right to refuse treatment and it it
won't affect my [__] they can't do
anything to you that you don't want them
to do to you right I can always delay
it but like I said if there's cancer in
there you want it out before it's too
late right you know what I
mean but if she's just [__] with me
giving me a biopsy to try to pck my ass
just because she don't like me you know
or because she really likes you yeah or
she likes me too much I you know what I
mean she's like and he I walk now I'm
going to have to go I walk out there
she's laughing she's laughing and
high-fiving the other nurses and [__]
they go we
got see I don't I'm a man I don't trust
them like taking pictures with their
yeah they're like they're like we got
that
[__] like taking that thing up
your ass yeah look how he's walking
we're
going I would think that doctors would
be more professional than that but you
never know no you never know no uhuh
uhuh no friends with doctors it never
really occurred to me like whenever I
was going to gynecologist and stuff like
that that they were doing that [__] but
I will I will say though that in all my
years of going to gynecologist I only
ever went to a male gynecologist once
and it was fine it was a little bit
weird but it was fine but every other
time I always went to a woman doctor cuz
dude they you know you go to a dude and
say yeah my period this and that they
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about they don't go through that [__] so
it's just kind of like I really
shouldn't need to go to a woman doctor
for this kind of stuff because at least
they know what you're talking about you
know
right I'm G to ask her you trying to get
me pegged aren you oh my God she like
what this shit's going to happen I'm
going to get my wife down here at the
camera
you don't know it you don't know my side
gig they got people that would pay for
that
[__] surprisingly yes yeah they will I
ain't GNA do that
though I've already made up my mind I I
want to see the second set of tests okay
and uh if I'm not satisfied with the
with those numbers that you know what I
mean I'm within the normal range yeah I
mean you know I wouldn't worry about it
if I were you it's just kind of like
well look it's like I have haven't had
insurance for years and years and I'm
just like I for all I know I could have
[__] cancer it's just like I don't
even want to go I don't want to know
it's like you know what I mean no I
don't think you do it's fine well I I
don't think I do either I check them
breasts all the time okay well there's
other kinds yeah I know we're just
worried about the [__] breast canc
that's the main one that's all he cares
about cuz he doesn't want the boobs
that's the one that gets women the most
is that one I don't um I don't think I
think get that damn ovarian cancer too
yeah and you know I have I don't have
any symptoms of that or nothing like
that symptoms yeah yeah well some kinds
of cancers there's there's not so you
really got to watch but you know what I
mean
um yeah murder Hornet said uh my dad has
prostate cancer doctor told him he'll
die of old age before the cancer yeah
because usually Camp gu says prostate
cancer is usually real slow a very slow
growing type of cancer in most cases in
most cases yeah so so I'm not worried
about it yeah like I said I'd be more
I'm I'm the kind of [__] only
like even when I had Insurance like I
have to be pretty much like feeling like
I'm going to die before I'll actually
see here's another [__] problem one
of the treatments if you got cancer and
is they put a radioactive pellet up
there next to that [__] who knows what
that does to you jiz I'm be telling
Jenny no Jenny we can't you can't
swallow that [__] give you cancer I'm
not I'm going to turn turn into the
toxic radio Radioactive [__] JZ and
[__] holy [__] that'd be kind of it
might it glows it might glow and [__]
like that we can make a whole kind
making all kinds of money we can make
like people be like that's fake it's
special effects oh no it's absolutely
real no I'll get that damn [__] out of
the glow sticks like they did for alien
like they not alien Predator see we're
thinking of like monetizing like every
single thing like I said people will pay
for some weird ass [__] and sometimes
look like the weirder it is the better
because it's you know the novelty of it
monetizing Tom Ross's
suffering
okay you ready to get on this [__] you
want to get on the ghost the crowd has
gotten
bigger yeah Z Would radioactive jizz uh
burn on the way out uh it' probably just
tingle it'd be it'd be like a cold
feeling kind of like electric like an
electric feeling might be kind of
pleasant right and the gays love it the
[__] goes up inside there and it [__]
goes in and then it's digested it it
goes throughout the [__] system you
kind of glow for you
glow you go to like you go to like a
[__] nightclub or something and the
you get under the lights and you're just
like yeah like a radioactive suppository
they could they could see all your like
innards and whatnot damn I gotta talk to
I gotta talk I gotta talk to Toby about
that Toby proba my buddy Toby probably
knows all about that I I would that's in
the leather daddy World they probably
know all about prostate stuff he's a
nurse that's you know to's a nurse he's
a male nurse he probably knows all about
that [__] oh yeah prostate yeah yeah you
probably go yeah you could probably ask
him about come on over I'll check
you that's probably exactly what he yeah
[__] that sound exactly like
something he Toby comes dressed like Mr
slave and
[__] he's got his leather cowboy hat on
and I ain't joking that's exact that's
how Toby [__] comes to the club with
his [__] all his [__] leather
straps on his beard [__] he's like go
ahead and lay down over there put your
feet up in the air yeah there you go
bend over time he's putting the gloves
on and [__] gets them all lubed and says
[__] it takes the glove off then L his
hand like I said long as I can film it
just so I can he he's like we're friends
you know what I mean we're friends I
don't a glove I mean yeah [__] F oh
my God I can totally see that happening
he's like Jen hold his
head he's like here give him something
to bite bite down on so he doesn't
scream he's like he's up to his [__]
shoulder see his hand like coming out
like your stomach and stuff like that oh
we can see look at all this money I talk
about all this perverted [__] and money
starts showing who's who's gave me some
money thank you Bryce thank you thank
you very much just tuned in all I'm
going to say is that instead of buying
that uh that coffee use your spare
change to support the show via super
chat or super thanks love the show keep
up the good one thank you very much
thank you we're going to get we're going
to get we're going to get we're going to
get we are I promise you know how we do
it's like we just got off on the and
this is this is absolutely Tom's fault
because I didn't even know where you
were going with this cuz you just
started with the all you said just
randomly you said so Jen's been wanting
to Peg me and then all then you went off
on this big long
Ty about been bothering me I got to get
it off my [__] chest man bother me
all [__] day you know what else that
[__] told me told me I couldn't ride
motorcycles until I did the test again
next week I was like what I didn't I
just started laughing and she got mad
that's we she's yeah don't ride
motorcycles start he rides the
motorcycle to the doctor's office yeah
I'm going to ride I'm going to ride that
bik anymore he uses my car if he needs a
car but he doesn't have I'm going to I'm
going to laugh at her I laughed at her
and I was like well maybe that's why
she's mad she like well now I'm
absolutely going to shove stuff up your
body yeah well it started that way when
I was at the
office I have an antagonistic
relationship with her well you're kind
of antagonistic just in general well I
told her I said you're making me mad and
she she started laughing so you making
me mad asking me all these questions and
[__] I mean that's kind of their job but
yeah yeah and then uh but
no she and then I looked it up and and I
was like prostate and motorcycles and
then it said yeah if you live if you're
always on a motorcycle like you're a
professional motorcycle rider or
something and you know that the
vibration and the seat can [__] cause
like swelling of the prostate and I'm
going who the [__] who the [__] are
these dudes what the [__] it's like why
would it just be a motorcycle why
wouldn't it be like riding a horse
sitting or sitting in a chair yeah
that'd be like a 100 times worse or
[__] like who the [__] are these
dudes man and I'm starting to think well
there so many sary people that just sit
around and do nothing I mean you can
grab some of these guys I could just
grab them and they'd bruise you know
what I mean just just at a cellular
level just [__] soft you know I guess
but I'm like how the hell does riding a
motorcycle [__] up your I don't I don't
understand it I I did also didn't buy it
I didn't believe it not not a word of
that's yeah that seems very specific
yeah well like I said any live in a
world of f sitting on anything You'
think for a long time [__] up here like
a truck driver or something like that
think like sitting in a truck we live in
a world of [__] extreme risk aversion
I mean you tell somebody there's a risk
and and they don't want to do it you
know what I mean [__] oh well well [__]
there's a risk of this there's a risk of
that there's a there's a risk in
everything you [__]
do man you know and also if you don't do
anything then you don't get stronger you
know if you're soft
all as it takes is just some dude who's
[__] strong to just [__] you up and
just really [__] you up all right but
that same dude who got [__] up had he
been training and getting stronger and
taking blows and being in the [__]
Dojo or whatever fighting with [__]
Cobra Kai and [__] he would have never
been [__] even he got
H resist it you know what I mean [__]
you you get a stronger body by putting
stress doesn't make you weak it makes
you stronger physical stress that's just
the only person that thinks that is like
people that think that old people okay
here we go I'm going to end this here in
a minute because we got to start the
show yeah was like but they got PE older
people thought the human body was like a
battery the more you did the weaker
you'd get oh don't overwork you'll get
it's like you're they're
conserving yeah I remember like older
people like my grandparents age like
saying that a human body was like a
battery the more you did the more it
would wear out out yeah no that is not
how it worked the opposite the more you
do and the more you eat the better you
nutrition the stronger you get the
longer you'll live because you're
fueling a fire and adding fuel to the
fire and the Fire gets bigger but you
just keep adding more fuel to the fire
you know it's like a biological fire
it's not a
battery and thinking this okay look I'm
not you know I'm not an anti-trump dude
okay I think the motherfucker's
hilarious clown I think he's a clown I
think he's [__] hilarious he's good
at certain I look at a dude like Trump
and he [__] thinks the body is a
battery he's one of those I could just
tell by his
bill he that he's one of those they all
kind of had that
look you don't want to do too much you
get weaker yeah that's well and like I
said that was a very comment cuz I
remember like people my grandparents age
saying stuff like that yeah yeah yeah
that is uh not the case I could just
tell by his build and the way he walks
and the way he does things that he's one
of
those Yeah well yeah you know I got
family members that are like that yeah a
lot like I said a lot of older people my
mom's like that that you do too much
then you break down yeah no not at all
nah the
opposite you got to keep doing [__] Yeah
Yeah the more active you stay the
stronger you'll be the longer you'll
live yeah you can't just like [__]
lay around yeah you will wear out then
yeah my dad was indifferent he didn't
care one way or the other he'll just sit
there and drink soda watch
TV yeah but he was born with a baby
bottle in his mouth that had [__]
pork grease in it that's old that was
also very common that's an old school
Southern that's like an old southern
thing yeah yeah they feeding them babies
pork fat make them healthy yeah make
them healthy cuz they wanted you to be
kind of fat yeah kind of fat yeah if you
weren't kind of fat then sickly yeah
yeah yeah white people and black people
of the South they were like that just
feed pork grease eat them a lot lot kind
of fat to be healthy yeah a lot of pasta
yeah a lot of potatoes Big Time a lot of
grits yeah Denny Rowling said and I had
forgotten all about this he said Michael
Douglas said he got throat cancer from
eating Katherine Zeta Jones's cancer is
coochie yeah he did say that it might be
true um still though it's I think I
think I think cancer can be
contagious if you inject somebody with
cancer cells that's it I mean in some
ways but it's just like even if that
were true which I doubt um it seems like
not real classy to like say that I keep
that low yeah I would
say I mean they were still married then
right so it's not like it was his ex and
he was just being an [__] and I'd be
like I mean if you said that [__] about
me I'd be like [__] you man like and and
you were as famous as they were and like
everybody heard that I'm like yeah
thanks a lot yeah I'd keep that low if
you're F thanks a lot but no there may
be something to that I heard some cancer
might be viral the viruses can cause the
cancer yeah I had heard that as well but
like I said I don't know if it's true in
his case also heard that there's a lot
of different kinds of cancer and it's
not all the same thing it just kind of
looks like the same thing that our
concept of cancer is incorrect there's
cancer like things but they're being
caused by different
things some of it's
viruses it's amazing and here's the
thing I'm pretty sure they can cure a
lot of that just that they make a lot of
money on treating it treating it I'm
convinced they can cure diabetes but
they don't really want to that's a lot
of money to treat diabetes the thing
about cancer is that it's not just
really one thing there's like lots of
different it's like a lot more
complicated yeah you say cancer it's a
group of stuff yeah it's not just one of
them
yeah Oracle said guess who's on vacation
this week oh well good for you oh Oracle
[Laughter]
is but yeah I you know I I don't know
okay let's get to the [__]
story that was a good warm up and
everybody you went off on like we we
went like flying up Tom's butthole for
there's a [__] ton of people in here
that audience is here when you start the
story flying up Tom's
butthole look she's trying to focus on
the
ass it's the way women are man [__] well
now not all women well now now I
Sinister women Sinister women are like
that Sinister creative are you saying
that I'm Sinister exactly you're
Sinister and creative well the thing
about it that just kind of ah heads up
is that the more uncomfortable it makes
you the more I'm going to do more they
do
it I do kind of laugh that's just how I
kind of laugh at it though because it's
funny that you get like uncomfortable so
then I'm just going to keep it's funny
poking at you think it's funny I
understand it's
funny I think it's funny I wouldn't have
brought it up if I didn't think funny
that's true because it's not like I said
about it you said about it you said
about it every man can relate every man
can relate they probably can yeah except
Zach Z what are you scared of man for
Zach jump up jump up in the air and come
down ass first on the end of a [__]
sure everybody's like what's the big
deal yeah he like he's landed on a fire
hydrant he could take it that boy he's a
[__] power bottom sure yeah I gotta
hook I gotta hook him up man gotta hook
gotta hook him up with Toby Toby might
be a little bit too old for him though I
imagine Zack K he likes him young
guys yeah yeah I suppose
so all right yeah how do can we can we
make like a good transition I guess from
from now that we're talking about we're
talking about ghost sea and sea moner
to ghost ships ghost ships Ghost Ship
not ghost shits no I didn't say that
ghost ships no I know but I was just
trying to make a transition between
between butts and ghosts okay you know
what I mean ghost
ships it's a creepy topic I have always
been like really creeped out by Ghost
Ship type story there's a ship out there
that's that that has been abandoned at
Sea I think it was a uh I think it was a
luxury liner wasn't it and every now and
then it shows up yeah they know where it
was is abandoned luxury liner it was
going to be towed to scrap but the line
that the tug but was pulling it with
broke and it [__] they lost it there
it went it lost in a it got lost in a uh
in a storm and every six or seven years
people see it out in the ocean creepy as
[__] that is creepy yeah I think we
covered that that in the last we
probably did because we like I said we
talked about a lot of ghost ships like
in the last one yeah and um and sea
monsters and stf to these ones like the
four that I picked are kind of more on
the Paranormal end okay um some of them
are like based on [__] that really
happened but then like people still see
the ships but they're not really sure
yeah if they're still there or not you
know what that one ship I was talking
about though I forgot what the name of
it it was locked up tight as a tick so
rain isn't getting into it hi POI
where'd you come from and
EV evidently it's still in good good
evidently is still in good
condition yeah floating out there like a
damn
Hotel an empty Hotel imagine
that yeah just thinking about it it was
like really spooky creepy and it would
been seen it see and it looked like it'
be in pretty good condition I think it's
spooky for the same reason that like
dead malls are spooky any kind of like
linal spaces um especially stuff like I
know there's like been kind of a big
thing in horror like analog horror and
then they did like back room
and that's kind of like a big thing too
where it's just like endless hallways of
just like empty [__] and there's like
nobody there and it's just like I think
that ghost ships are kind of creepy for
the same reason as that with the added
creepiness of being like out in the
middle of the [__] ocean which is
inherently scary on own and nobody sees
it yeah and when they do see it and
report it it's like every five or six
years it's I think it's been out there
by now by at least 20 years yeah I mean
just floating around so it's just kind
of like floating around they said it's
carried it's being carried by a current
that's kind of circular and it goes
throughout the continent
it's going to be out there forever I
always wonder there's got to be like
some kind of people that are like Ghost
Ship spotters that like just go out
specifically and see if they can find
like a specific Ghost Ship you know what
I mean I imagine it's seen more often
than reported and people didn't know it
was a ghost ship they just see it in the
distance yeah because you wouldn't
necessarily know unless you got close
enough to it right like what ship it was
you would just think oh it's another
ship you know what I mean that's not
spooky and you pass it you don't even
think about it but you know it's like I
said the o on its own is just [__]
creepy like thinking about how [__]
deep the ocean is and man I had a
nightmare like that last night I think
about like I was I can't even remember
what it was but it was just kind of like
they were talking about how deep this
section of this ocean was and it was
just like this they're like this island
or whatever that had these big tall
buildings on it it's like eight of those
deep and I was just like holy [__] it
was just like this and it was like
really creepy and it like woke me up it
was so scary well we're only thinking in
terms of the Earth right watching that
other program that I listen to called
Event Horizon it's really good guy has
all these scientists and astronomers
anding astrophysicists and [__] on they
just found an exoplanet a planet around
another star I think it's about 40 or 50
light years away if I remember correctly
and I I don't think it has a name it's
just just a bunch of numbers and letters
yeah they don't usually give them any
cool names until later and and it's it's
an ocean planet it doesn't have a
surface and by the spectroscopy that's
coming off of it they believe that that
ocean is like 600 miles deep [__] I
don't I don't even want to think about
that imagine that that's giving me
anxiety yeah and it's three or four
times the size of
Earth physically and the mass and
everything can you imagine what kind of
love crafty and hellbeasts are like
maybe swimming around 600
mile deep I don't even want to think
about that oh that that's going to give
me nightmares tonight so thanks for that
so if you're on the surface of that [__]
if you could see to the bottom it would
be like you were in space
yeah looking down at the surface of the
planet that is so [__] creepy that is
like one of the creepiest things that I
can [__] think of Hugo says also
triangle is a good flick it is I agree
that is a very good flick I don't think
you've ever seen it but it's just kind
of it's kind of related because it's
about this these people that find um
this supposedly Abandoned Ship like they
kind of go out and they kind of you know
wreck and they find this abandoned ship
and then I don't want to spoil it
because it doesn't go the way you think
think it's going to go but they kind of
go on there and um it looks like people
were just there but everybody's gone
that's all I'm GNA say but it's really
really good if you haven't seen I think
it's actually on 2B so you can watch it
for I think I might be wrong I believe
that planet might have been called
Trappist like a monk Trappist D I think
is what it was and it wasn't like it
wasn't 600 miles it was like 300 miles
which is still a lot I mean still still
a lot trais D I think is what it's
called man imagine
that do they think it has life on it
no probably well they don't know well
yeah there might like I said there might
be all kind of scary [__] like swim the
ocean seems to be the
atmosphere that's the atmosphere that's
crazy yeah but I mean it's not that
crazy when you really think about it but
yeah that is pretty weird that's pretty
weird yeah I'm I'm going to have to look
that up cuz it's called Trappist I
believe although like I said that's
probably going to give me nightmares
thinking about like super deep water
like with big [__] swimming around in it
it's like my
that's like one of the scariest things
in the world to me it had pretty heavy G
I think it was like I think it was like
four or five times the size of
Earth had pretty heavy
gravitational forces in it I don't know
if you could fall to the bottom the
density and the pressure you might just
hang you get down so far and then you
just hang there you couldn't fall any
deeper probably yikes because the
pressure who knows a human would be
killed you know you would fall that far
and you into that and you you'd be
crushed but they know it's
water wild H yeah that is it's in the
habitable zone yeah yeah it's not frozen
it's habitable habitable zone
temperatures Zach said a show about the
back rooms Lial spaces Trend would be
cool as hell I kind of agree I was
watching um I guess it was nexo and he
did a um or they did a like a show about
that about back rooms and stuff like
that and I think like Ryan Hollinger did
one too but I I don't know I'm
fascinated by that kind of stuff I love
all the analog horror stuff there and I
know that that's kind
of I don't I don't want to say that's p
a now because it's still kind of going
on but I think the back rooms thing like
has kind of taken over a little bit you
know analog horror is still around
obviously Cas skin marink just came out
which was like analog horror RIT large
that's like the quintessential analog
horror film but you know which I really
liked it but um a lot of people really
did not like it and I get that I get
that um Oracle says there's a great
novel about a haunted ship called the
devil in the Dark Water Jenny you might
like it that does sound really good I've
actually heard that title before but I
don't think I've ever read it murder
horn is asking Hugo if it's Netflix I'm
guessing I'm guessing he's asking about
triangle I think last time I looked
triangle was on 2B for free I think it
used to be
but I've seen it a couple times and it's
really really good I think I even wrote
about it I don't remember if I did a
video about it but I wrote about it on
my blog yeah get ice my ice all melted
yeah my ice all
melted all right so do you want me to
wait till you come back and then we get
started all right so let's kind of get
started on some of these Ghost Ship
stories so this one I guess this is a
pretty famous case in like Canada
but I don't remember ever hearing about
it before I started like researching
this one because I like I said I wanted
to find some different ones then and
like I said these are more on the
Paranormal end I kind of felt like when
we talked about ghost ships before yeah
we did seea monsters and stuff too but
we talked about like technically like
ghost ships where they're floating out
there with nobody in them and [__] like
that these ones are kind of more on the
Paranormal end so this is the famous
case of the Flaming ghost ship of North
umberland
straet now thank you North umberland
straight is between uh Nova Scotia New
Brunswick and Prince Edward Island uh in
Canada now this Legend has been around
for more than 200 years so this ship um
is a three masted
Schooner and there's apparently like a
really lot of sightings of it now the
crazy thing about this is that when
people report seeing it they don't just
see you know a ship like coming out of
the fog and then disappearing or
whatever this ship appears to be on
fire so the folklore surrounding this
ship um is that it usually um it's
usually spotted
before a storm which that's a very
common thing about uh certain Ghost Ship
Legends is that it's like a like a bad
Omen um you know you see it and then
there's like a bad storm coming or
something like that um there's been many
many sightings of this uh ship
apparently uh throughout the decades um
most people seem to see it in the fall
like in the Autumn the most recent
sighting that I could find on the inter
was from
2008 um this was a 17-year-old uh guy
and he saw it as he was looking across
the bay in like um mid January of 2008
it was kind of reported in the newspaper
at the time that he had seen it now some
people that see this ship um they say
that sometimes before you see it you
hear cannon fire and then you see this
big ball of flame that can usually be
seen from multiple angles at once that's
another thing that's been
reported now another thing that's
commonly reported which is really creepy
because like I said if it was just light
you know people would say like oh it's
just you know auroras or it's like a
trick of the light or it's an optical
illusion or whatever but one thing that
a lot of people have seen it have
reported is that they see this ship it
comes out of a fog bank or whatever and
it's on fire and they very clearly see
people running around on the deck and
jumping overboard you know what I mean
so much so that there have been multiple
cases of you know boat Crews and stuff
like that that were like on the shore
that saw it and thought it was a real
ship and like got in boats and like went
out there to help the people because
they thought that they were dying you
know what I mean and then they get out
there and there's nothing there you know
what I'm saying so it's like that's a
pretty common thing that's reported now
one of these happened there was one that
was reported in 19 00 and this happened
in charlott town
Harbor now there was a group of sailors
they were on the shore and they saw the
ship like come out of the thing and like
I said it's just they said very clearly
they saw this big ship a three masted
Schooner it was on fire there were
people running around frantically on the
deck like they were trying to put the
fire out people were jumping overboard
and stuff like that and so they got all
they all jumped in their rowboats and
went out there to rescue the crew and
when they got out there the ship
disappeared they sent divers out they
sent other boats out like looking to see
where it was and it was not there they
didn't find anything so this first ship
apparently like this the first sighting
of this ship that was reported was in
1786 and this was a sighting that from
um seow Head Lighthouse which is a great
[__] name for a lighthouse sea cow
head what is a sea cow head well I guess
the head of a sea cow what is a sea cow
like a manate oh okay that's what
they're talking about manatees head like
a manatee head manatees where is this
this is in um like Canada like up around
um man Nova Scotia yeah but they but sea
it's like a different okay it's it's the
same family though that's a Florida
thing no C it's a different thing well
yeah but like in the like in Australia
and stuff like that they have like a
like a dong or whatever which is kind of
the same thing okay they're not exactly
the same species I don't I don't think
but they're very similar like it's in
the same family good so apparently in
1786 The lighthous Keeper of the seow
Head Lighthouse he saw the ship like
he's looking out and he's just like holy
[__] there's this like he's like the
sails were all out and there was a storm
going on and it was coming toward I
don't think it was on fire when he first
saw it but it looked like he said it she
just looked like a regular [__] but it
was coming in um and that it was going
to hit the rocks like at the cliff base
and then he said that it kind of turned
into the storm and it disappeared but
they found out later like they never did
find it so they also found out later
like there was another story where there
were all these other guys who were
working in Charlotte Town and out in the
harbor again there was this big sailing
vessel and it was they all saw it and it
was on fire so they all see the guys
like running around on the deck and they
like um like people are jumping off and
so they got like the everybody got in
the rescue boat and they go out there to
get it to help them but the um when they
got before they got out there this like
big fog came up and like just kind of
went went over the ship and then when
they got to the place where the ship had
been it was
gone so they actually have this is what
the guy
said that wrote down that he saw it he
said as it came nearer it seemed seemed
to lose speed and as it came opposite
our house it stopped still I said to
Fred who was another guy um perhaps
they're coming ashore we got up on the
banks to watch there was no sign of
anyone on board and no Dory on toe I
can't remember just how long it was but
I think about 10 minutes after she
stopped I saw smoke Rising very slow all
over the deck so these people are
looking at it for a long time which was
a pretty common thing what year was this
again well this this took place in like
the early 1900s okay
um he said then it was only a few
minutes I saw men that seemed to come
from below and they were running around
the deck every way then as they were
running around I saw a low flame all
over the deck when the flame started the
men climbed up the masts of the vessel
when they were about halfway up the
masts the sails caught all the sails
seemed to catch at the same time I
couldn't see the men anymore as the
Flames hid my view we watched it until
the Flames died and everything crumbled
to the deck there was nothing left but
the hull on the water and gradually it
seemed to sink lower and finally
disappeared as if it gradually filled
with water and sunk I wonder how long
that took so but yeah but that seems
like a pretty common thing with this
particular legend or whatever is that
the people that see it they seem to like
sit there and watch it for a while like
it just like it's this whole thing and
like a lot of times like I said it
looked realistic enough that they
thought it was a real [__]
[__] so um yeah so and and other like
Mariners have seen this as well so it's
not just like they're imagining [__] or
anything like that so in there was also
a sting in
1973 there was a guy named Marvin McLoud
and he was driving home he wasn't on a
ship or anything like that but he was
driving home like um around like the
road that was near the shore at about
like a little past midnight and he said
the night was really clear it was kind
of cold out um and he said he had
binoculars with him cuz it was hunting
season and then he said from the the car
he said he saw what appeared to be a
three-masted schooner with its sails on
fire and people running around the deck
and jumping overboard then he said I was
about to head home and call the Coast
Guard when it up and disappeared before
my eyes so very very common like I said
and there was another sighting in
October of
1978 um there was a lightkeeper at uh
place called wood Islands his name was
Leon Patton and he got a phone call from
a woman who lived in town like you know
and she could see the water from her
house she called and said what are you
burning and he said I'm not burning
anything and she said why don't you look
out one of your east facing windows and
tell me what you see so he looked out
there and he could see the ship like
heading down and it was just like this
[__] ship that was on fire he watched
it for a few minutes and then it
vanished Into Thin Air so there was that
too and like I said you could see it
from like different
uh angles apparently because she was
seeing it from a different and then she
called him and said hey look this the
70s that was the 70s yeah what everyone
was on drugs then is that what you were
Ling or no no I'm just trying to keep
track of these of these sightings and
who is saying this where was the source
do you know like uh well that guy was
that guy was the Lighthouse Keeper okay
disar and he said he got a phone call
from a from a local woman that like
lived right down the street you you know
where this story appeared like where the
source was it appeared a book or a
newspaper some of these were in
newspapers um there was somebody that uh
wrote a book that kind of compiled all
of these but I'm assuming he got them
from like newspaper reports okay you
know what I'm saying all right so this
is kind of a famous Ghost Ship sighting
yeah like I said I hadn't really heard
of this one but like I said it's
Canadian so it's just like I didn't
really like it wasn't really on my radar
kind of makes me think of that old song
by um Warren zon what is it Edmund
Fitzgerald that's not Warren zon that's
Gordon light foot Gordon Lightfoot
that's right Warren zon did did uh
Warren zon did [__] roll in the
Headless Thompson Gunner yeah which is
also a good song yeah yeah but yeah
every time we do a ghost ship show or I
think about ghost ships I always like
the wreck of the em and Fitzgerald like
just starts playing in my head yeah you
never heard that song you guys need to
listen to I love that song actually
there old Seaman song I love all those
creepy songs like that even though they
weren't SE they were in the Great Lakes
yeah yeah yeah cuz that was a real yeah
story like he was writing about yeah
those dudes all died they found that
ship later they did yeah and the dude
and and what was funny is like one of
the dude was still at the hell his dead
body he's standing there in there it's
creepy just like a Dracula that frigid
ass water his body was
preserved see that's like so creepy to
me that's so [__] creepy zie yeah he
look like a zombie he's still down there
can you imagine [__] finding that you
would never get that image out of your
head I've seen the photographs yeah
that's like why is my phone ringing I
don't know it says spam risk I can see
it yeah there was he wasn't at the helm
he was he was in he was in the uh he was
on the bridge yeah Lo looked like he was
looking out the window I I think he I
think he got
killed when the ship hit the bottom
because there's a lot of
impact uh I don't because it hit the
bottom pretty quick I he probably hadn't
fully
drowned by the time he hit the bottom
maybe we'll see but uh yeah the bodies
are preserved they're still down the
photographs they went down there many
many years later I think maybe the '90s
or the ' 80s or '90s they found that
ship degerald yeah you guys can Google
it and you can Google photographs and
you'll see the bodies looking out the
window it's creepy look like Eddie from
Iron Maiden looking out the [__]
window yeah and like I said it's like
that's such a creepy song too yeah I
don't know why there's just something
inherently creepy about [__] that
happens like on ships well the way he
told the story in this in in in in in
the song is compelling yeah you know
about how the [__] cook says all
right I I'll be seeing you guys later
[__] they knew they were going under
been good been good working with you
yeah they they they all died I can't
imagine being that chill like if you
knew you were dying but maybe I don't
know they took on water they were in a
storm and they took on water there's
fridg of cold water up in the Great
Lakes something something broke open and
the water went down into the hold and it
capsized and went down yeah like you
said that actually wasn't in the ocean
though that was like in the Great Lakes
will be the ocean though I mean yeah
because there's a lot of shipwrecks in
the [__] in the yeah it's not salt
water it's fresh water yeah and uh
there's huge sturgeon in there like the
size of a they're like [__] 30 foot
long 20 foot long sturgeon the size of a
shark it's amazing the great legs
American great legs yeah yeah they're
big y'all around when I was living up in
Michigan they'd all talk about the
[__] Great Lakes where's [__]
where's my boy he's not in here gther
hasn't been here a while yeah I don't
know he got bored with the show or busy
went to high school with him but he's up
in Michigan still yeah yeah I mean like
like I said if you're not from the US
like the Great Lakes are yeah [__]
massive the northern regions of the
United States like Michigan and
everything Michigan is the Americans
America's version of
Siberia it's where all the cars and all
the industrial might was Detroit they
made cars and tanks kind of like our
version of tanko grad during World War
II you know they were big in the big in
the war effort
and unions slowly took over and
strangled the place out bad politics and
Detroit collapsed and RI race riots
happened and it went it went apocalyptic
a long time I lived in Detroit I lived
in C second in West Hancock right off of
Cass Corridor which is the [__] worst
places in Detroit is where I lived I
[__] loved it though for a while had
a great goth Scene It was during the
time of like the crow the crow was being
play it is being set in the place in the
time when I was there thank you murder
Hornet just the tip
yeah s um Sophie who comes sometimes
she's on the show friend of ours she's
from Michigan and is like related to the
little sister of one of my best high
school friends that's how I met her
through the show and she comes over but
sof's like my little sister or like my
daughter and they have all that they
have that look and it's funny to see her
she has that Michigan look as big that
Scandinavian Michigan look but when
you're talking about the great lakes and
the Ed wreck of the Ed and fitgerald and
everything it kind of like brings back a
kind of a
weird uh what do they call it it's kind
of like a Nostalgia for that place you
know what I mean it's like yeah it's a
totally different version of America of
lived all over the United States I'm
actually more of a southern guy you know
Mississippi but the north has its own
thing too it's very different but it
is it's respectable they they got the
wrong way of doing things up there well
I mean the US is kind of like 50
different countries 50 different
countries United yeah pretty much we
watch the same television and we speak
the same language but other than that
there's not a lot in common I mean
there's some things in common there's
probably more things in common than not
but there's like a lot of the everyday
living experience is very different
there's a lot of differen I lived in
Boston for about six years and there's
nothing Boston the life in downtown
Boston has nothing to do with
Mississippi nothing or even Florida well
it's weird cuz was reading an article
the other day and they were talking
about and I guess it was somebody that
coming from like a
Midwestern uh point of view which I've
never been to the Midwest and so it was
like they were talking about oh the
Friday fish fry and I knew that that was
like a Catholic tradition and it's just
like but it's just so weird to me
because it's like that was not even a
thing that was like on our radar but I
guess like in Catholic majority areas
that's kind of a big deal and I guess
it's still a big deal like in some areas
of the Midwest which I was like wow
they're still doing that that's crazy I
went and went on um and started just
Googling uh [__] what's it like to
live in Florida and it's always New
Yorkers talking about because they move
here a lot and the main complaint are
these [__] Italian ass guidos coming
here complaining about that they can't
get pizza if you're really Italian you
make your own [__] Pizza okay yeah I
mean I'm not a [__] you don't need
look you Italians I respect your [__]
[__] I could cook all your [__] too
all right if you're that [__] Italian
that you have to have some New York
Pizza learn to make your own [__]
Pizza all right it's not as hard as
that's what I would it's not that hard
if you want it that bad I make a badass
Pizza I love Italian food I like Italian
culture you know I leaving in Brazil was
also in a romance culture and um Brazil
has a lot huge Italian influence to it
uh Italy Portugal Spain you know and
also turkey surprisingly a lot of
Turkish influence in
Brazil but uh no all that Italian food
that you were getting up in New York
that you you can't live without you can
get the ingredients to make it here all
right yeah I mean like I said you can
get okay pizza here it's corporate Pizza
yeah corporate so it's like if you
really must have pizza and you're not
that picky yeah you can get some pizza
yeah you can get Papa jobs and [__]
[__] like that and there's like Mom
and Pop places that are pretty good and
[__] like
but it's just kind of like yeah if you
if you want it done like a specific way
then you probably need to like make it
yourself they want to cry about it they
want to be [__] about it come on it's
going to take you about a year to get
that crust right yeah you know yeah I
will say it's not as easy as it but it's
going to take to get it exactly the way
you want it to there's a lot of
variables right too many variables but
but if you're that [__] Italian you
need to get get your ass in the kitchen
make your own [__] you can even make
your own mozzarella you can make your
own mozzarella you make your own
marinara you make all that okay and I'm
not even Italian and I can do all that
okay but no I know what you're talking
about it's we we don't have th those
type of restaurants here it's all
corporate stuff but you can do it
yourself I do yeah bad Pizza there are
little mom and pop places like you know
and so that's going to be hit and miss
yeah and I mean I'm sure if you look you
can find good [__] anywhere but it's
just like I know it's kind of a pain in
the a like have and if you're so Jewish
you got to have Kish and [__] all right
you can make your own Kish okay [__]
matab balls yeah because I can't really
think of any good Jewish delies around
here now that I'm thinking about it I
used to get good condition condition in
Boston well yeah you can find [__] up
but I can make that right you know so
I'm just trying to well obviously like
we live in Eustace which is kind of
rural so obviously there's not going to
be anything like that out here but even
in Orlando I'm sure there's got to be a
couple but it's just like I can't really
think of any off hand yeah like any
really good Jewish jellies or no
anything like that there's not enough
Jews here I mean there are but yeah it's
just kind of seems like they're like
[__] it we're just going to make they're
spread out yeah so you're not going to
maybe there's not as much yeah you can't
concentrate them now I will say that we
got good Indian food I was just going to
say like in particularly in Lake Mary
yeah um which is near where we used to
live it's kind of like a suburb of
Orlando I guess there's a really good
Indian restaurant got good Indian food
called Memories of Indian we got great
authentic Mexican and Central American
yeah there's a lot of really good cuz we
got these Farm Workers here we got real
me real [__] taco trucks out by the
farms and everything like that all kind
of good [__] and they're from every but
selling boiled peanuts yeah and they're
from they're from Central America that
shit's [__] legit you know but you
see I'm I'm growing tomatillos
tomatillos and making my own green salsa
and [__] that green salsa was good would
it and I learned a lot of [__] from K of
vlon my friend from Mexico who's a
friend of the show he showed me all the
girls to listen to on YouTube the cooks
on to listen to man [__] cooking con
Claudia I really recommend that's he
recommended and I recommend Claudia
cooking con Claudia she'll teach you how
to make all those Mexican
dishes how to make carnitas in a [__]
insta poot all
right we're getting on food here hold on
we had a food show okay but we're
getting on food well James said uh about
the fish fry thing he said oh it's still
a big deal in Madison Wisconsin yeah I
mean I had heard of it before but that
wasn't really a thing like in Florida I
guess and I didn't know that it was
still a thing I thought that was like an
old person thing but I guess not because
I saw an article the other day I'm like
oh that apparently is still a thing
that's crazy the the South fish thing is
Catfish which is a good fish yeah uh
it's like eel very soft
flaky uh not very fishy flavored
actually uh fish uh you won't get that
anywhere else and in other countries
that's a
delicacy and it's actually hard to find
here corporate you usually that to catch
it or you have to go look for it
catfish yeah easy to cook although there
are some kind of like water side like
kind of dive restaurants type places
where you can get catfish and alligator
and yeah what you call it has it yeah
what's the name of the place we just
went there uh uh the trough yeah trough
has the trough the trough t r FF yeah
the trough is good it is good actually
really trough in Florida yeah it's got
like it's known for oysters but they
have like a bunch of other stuff like I
said it's just a dinky little yeah hole
in the wall kind of yeah and and you buy
you buy [__] based upon what the market
price is right yeah Camp guy says Mellow
Mushroom is pretty good for more
expensive pizza experience yeah I'll
agree I've only been to Mellow Mushroom
a couple times and there actually is a
Mellow Mushroom probably only about 10
miles up the road from us maybe farther
than that yeah but I've been to them
before yeah that is not that's not what
those that's not what Italians New York
Italians are looking for for though
that's not that's not what they're
looking for not the right kind of pizza
they're looking for something kind of
based more about lombardis type that's
the which is a it's cooked in a
Kil uh it's uh H it don't matter hold
on I don't want to get involved on what
it
[Laughter]
is yeah Oracle said it's like being a
Texan and complaining you can't buy good
chili blasphemy you make your own damn
chili yeah I mean that's usually what we
do we just kind of there are some good
restaurants around here but I will even
note that even
in like rural ass Eustace right up the
street from us there was a really really
good
Japanese uh sushi restaurant that also
has like you know you can get um what do
you call it
uh H why did I just forget the word you
know what I mean not just sushi but just
you know you can get Bento boxes and
um and the word that I can't remember
remember but yeah you can get all that
kind of stuff and it's really it's a
little pricey I will say little pricey
but um the food is really good we
haven't been there in a while cuz it's
kind of expensive but you know what I
mean so you can get good food around
here but you got to you got to look
that's all I got to say I guess that's
true of everywhere but um all right so
where were we I kind of lost my place
now okay so back to the ghost ships I
guess even though Tom's GNA probably
gonna come back and talk about food some
more but that's okay
all right so there was another sighting
I don't think I talked about this one
yet so there was another sighting of
this ship in
1988 now it was actually seen at this
time not from the shore but from the
fery uh so the crew of the ferry
actually saw the ship and pointed the
radar at it uh it didn't come up on the
radar though but apparently they all saw
it um and they you know the the guy one
of the guys that was on the crew like
the or the captain rather he said that
we had um he's like so I kind of knew
what it was because I remembered we had
been on the ferry one night and we saw
the same thing like we saw the ship and
it looked like it was on fire and we're
like holy [__] we need to like go help
them and everything like that but then
like they got there and there was
nothing there so he was just kind of
like okay well I know what that is so
there was also that same night that that
happened that they saw it from the ferry
there was also a couple that lived right
around that area and they saw the ship
from their window like the window of the
bedroom and they said that the ship was
sailing like super fast like way more
fast than like an actual ship would be
able to sail but they had heard the
legends about it I don't know if they'd
ever seen it before but they had heard
the Legend So they kind of knew what it
was so they didn't like really call
anybody because they're like oh that
must be that ghost ship we've heard so
much about you know what I mean there's
also this other guy
um who lives in the same area his name
was Larry Hooper and he saw it twice um
he saw it some in the
1980s and he was actually worked on
there was a bridge um over like uh
called the prince Nova bridge and he
worked on there he was like the lookout
and he's like about 10 p.m. he saw it
and he said it was a clear night You
Could See For Miles the sails were on
fire with people all around the deck
then it disappeared
now this same guy saw it again like 10
years later like in the late 1990s and
he saw it from a car this time he said
like him and one of his relatives were
driving along the road along the shore
and they saw very clearly like this
flaming ship and like all these people
running around in the deck and then it
disappeared it's weird yeah which is
like a really creepy that's a really
creepy [__] image can you imagine the
stories are to be believed yeah I mean
well and like I said there have I don't
know it's like I don't there I didn't
see it right I wasn't there I didn't see
it but it's just like it does seem like
a lot of people are like describing it
the same kind of way you know what I
mean um so yeah there was a book called
The Phantom ship uh that had like all
lot of these sightings in it and stuff
like a guy named Roland Sherwood wrote
it and uh that guy who wrote the book
also said that he had seen it uh two
times also um I don't know if this book
is still in print or not but um there's
still some copies of it I guess like in
the local public library and stuff but I
guess it's apparently kind of hard to
get hold of so obviously Skeptics are
going to say that this is just an
optical illusion or um St Alba's fire
that's another thing they say a lot or
it's just like Moonlight like reflecting
through a fog bank or some people said
it's just like methane gas like burning
on the surface of the water something
like that but the thing about it is that
I don't know this is on like a lot of
ghost story sites and they kind of go
through this Litany of like all these
sightings of it which are all really
similar so I'm not really
sure what I want to believe about this
because I don't really
think I don't know man like this kind of
stuff the the C like plays tricks on
people well another thing is is
that you can write anything in a book
mhm you can say yeah uh 45 Witnesses saw
this on a certain date and this and if
if the source isn't given you're not
really
sure so you know because you can just
write anything yeah and then there were
also newspapers weren't all that
credible newspapers in the United States
[__] print [__] all the time they
always have well they just wanted to
sell so you know what I mean they were
just printing whatever and a lot of
times somebody came to them with a crazy
story they're like all right put that in
there and a lot of times you know
they're like we need we need something
that'll sell today and they'll come up
with an Airship story and it's obvious
obviously to to the writer to the guys
at the office They're laughing this is
some fabricated [__] you know and they
think it's more like a joke other people
are taking it seriously you know it's
hard to
say it's just know maybe they're seeing
a ghost [__] maybe they aren't there's
no way of knowing when you hear stories
like this all you can do is just be
entertained
right I mean I do like I mean the
imagery of it is really creepy cuz I
could just imagine driving down the side
like you know driving on the road like
one dark night like on the side of the
water and seeing this like this ship com
out it's all on fire and be like running
around and stuff that would be like
super creepy right super creepy yeah so
I can see how like it's really appealing
like as a yeah and spreading the stories
too yeah right that's what I'm saying
I'm not saying that like the people that
said they saw it didn't see anything I'm
just saying that you know it might be
fabricated it's a pretty compelling
image yeah and you know it might people
might just uh it might behoove them to
say they saw it or you know embellish
some [__] that they saw or yeah you
know like I said and and I've said this
it doesn't have anything to do with the
ghost [__] but like one of the weirdest
things I ever saw was when I was driving
yeah I know you yeah back to work one
night it was it wasn't late it was
probably only like probably between 8
and 9 I want to say maybe earlier and I
was just driving home and I saw what I
thought I didn't think it was a UFO I at
no time did I think it was a UFO I
actually thought it was um an asteroid
and I thought it was so it looked so big
and so flaming that I was like well
we're going the way of the dinosaurs
that's what you thought it was big
meteor going it was a big [__] I
thought it was a Planet Killer yeah cuz
that's what it looked like like well no
like the F okay the first thing I
thought of was a plane blew up that's
the first thing I thought and then I'm
like looking at it and I'm like that
looks like a [__] meteor I was like
but that's a meteor we are in big
[__] trouble right now because that
is massive you know what I mean because
you could tell like it was almost as big
as like the moon would have looked which
so you know it would have been big and
it was like flaming it was like it
looked like it was on fire and so I was
kind of freaking out so like I got back
to work and I'm like did you actually
just look outside did you see that and
then I was like looking on the internet
like trying to see him like apparently
nobody thought but me so maybe I'm crazy
I don't know I never did find out what
it was probably a meteor coming pretty
much straight at you that's what it must
have been that's what it must have been
like I said my my first thought was was
an exploding plane that was my first
thought but um but then after I said
that looks just like a [__] metor
like I said it didn't help that I had
just read a book called Death from the
skies yeah that was that was about all
the ways like all the [__] from space
that could kill you you know like a
non-fiction book which is a great book
by the way it's really entertaining but
it's also like pretty scary so I had
just read that like not too long ago so
I'm like oh well we're getting wiped out
so probably was a meteor coming straight
at you when she told me about it I
thought about it you know I kept getting
asking her over and over again how big
it was you know like if you held it up
she said if you held it up it' probably
about a size of a quarter yeah that's
about right that maybe slightly bigger
maybe a half dollar half dollar maybe so
probably what it was is it was a small
meteor coming basically at her in her
Direction it must have been coming right
so it just getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and then it maybe just burned out
and then it just burned out but it
looked so big wasn't that big it's just
that it was close maybe a mile away when
it fell apart maybe that's what it was
something like that because it would a
meteor the size of a baseball a mile
away burning burning up would look big
yeah cuz the plasma around it would look
big yeah you wouldn't have
any way to judge how big it was because
there's nothing next to it right you
know and it just burned out and turned
into little glowing it must cuz
obviously we're still walking around
that and that was
ground that was before I met you even
yeah it probably burned up a a mile or
so away from you maybe so but yeah it
was probably as it was burning up it was
probably only like the size of an acorn
it was pretty weird too the way that no
one else saw it like or nobody else like
said anything the angle it was coming
straight at you from a distance it
probably didn't look that impressive it
probably just L like a line but it's
like it's not like it was the middle of
the night and no one else was around it
was only like like 8:00 at night or
something you just had well they don't
last long you have to be looking in the
right and and other people disregarded
it cuz they knew what it was maybe yeah
Fallen star from a distance it was just
look like a line like a falling star but
from your point of view it was just it
looked like a huge Fireball coming
straight at you it looked like a huge
Fireball like I said that looked like I
thought a plane exploded this is what I
thought and it nothing hit the ground it
probably just turned into little
droplets yeah you know so yeah so
apparently the the Flaming Ghost Ship of
North umberland straet is so popular in
Canada that
there was well there was a song that
came out in 1988 by a guy named uh Lenny
Gallant I guess and he's just kind of
like a Canadian singer songwriter and he
did a song about it and that kind of
like made it more popular like in the
80s and in
2014 uh the post office the Canadian
like post they put out a stamp with the
Ghost Ship on it which I thought was
kind of cool like they put out they they
had like a whole series of stamps like
based on Canadian ghost stories that
they put out on Friday the 13th of that
year which I thought was like kind of a
neat idea but so yeah they even have
like a ghost ship of North umberland
straight like stamp in Canada which I
thought was pretty cool but like I said
I don't know if anyone has claimed to
have seen it since 2008 that seemed to
be like the most recent um sighting that
I could find of it there might be more
recent ones like that are just floating
around out there but that's kind of the
most recent one that was like documented
quote unquote that was like in a
newspaper and [__] like that you know
what I mean like other people might just
be on paranormal forums or whatever and
said oh yeah I saw that [__] you know
what I mean but you can't like really
back that up I mean you can't really
back up the other [__] either to be
honest with you but yeah so um all right
so this next story I actually have I
have photographs for this so this is
like pretty this isn't
necessarily it's kind of like a ghost
ship story but it's more like a ghost
like that ghosts that have to do with a
ship kind of story so this is the story
of the SS Water
Town so this was this happened in
1924 so the ship the SS Watertown is
sailing in the Pacific uh in December of
1924 like I said and there were two guys
on the crew one was named James Courtney
and one was named Michael Mian and they
were down in like the cargo kind of area
like working down there like they're
cleaning or something like that and
apparently some pipe busted somewhere or
something like that and filled the area
with like some kind of noxious gas um
and apparently they didn't they weren't
aware of it you know what I mean so I
guess it was a gas that they didn't like
they couldn't smell it or anything and
pretty much immediately both of them uh
collapsed like and you know look at poke
she went underneath the carpet did she
really she's underneath the damn carpet
well hi it's ridiculous she went
underneath the damn carpet underneath
the rug she's underneath the underneath
the throw rug it's a little prayer rug
she's underneath what are you doing
underneath there she's like I'm hiding
shut up okay I see you you can't see me
yeah [__] fny she's hiding yeah yeah
she's like completely underneath
completely underneath under underneath
the rug I can't see me yeah okay fat
where did Pooky go yeah where did she
go disappearing Pooky say Oracle she's
crazy she's always trying to get under
there I don't know why and there's like
a huge lump like she thinks we can't
here I can't see you pokey I have no
idea where you went but yeah so these
two guys are down there and the the gas
escapes and they like pass out now a guy
apparently like another guy I guess he
maybe knew what was going on somehow or
something and he tried to come down to
help them like he he went through this
he crawled through this like little pipe
or some [__] like to get down there like
help them and he pulled them both out
but I think by the time that he pulled
them both out it was too late like they
were already dead um and the guy that
went in there to save them he was also
kind of um he lived but it took like
half an hour for him to kind of like get
back because the fumes were like really
bad right but um but he couldn't save
the two guys he did try but it was too
late so the two guys died and as they
would do on a ship when some of the crew
died they had like a little funeral on
the ship and then they you know they put
the bodies out to see because that's
just what they would do the next day
though right before
Sunset the first mate of the ship said
that he was looking off the port side
and that he saw the two guys faces like
in the water like in the
waves and he's like he looked at them
and he said he saw their faces and he
recognized them and stuff and he just
saw them for about 10 seconds and then
they just kind of like faded away
and then over the next few days like
several other crew members also reported
seeing these two guys faces in the
water now the ship gets to New Orleans
and the captain whose name was Keith
Tracy he told um his employers it's like
man all the crew have been like these
two guys died on the ship and now
everybody's been seeing like their faces
like like in the waves like on the side
of the ship you know what I mean so the
guy like his boss or whatever is like
well why don't you try to take a picture
and like you know try to take a picture
of
it so they did that so they go back out
they take pictures when they see the
faces I remember this yeah you probably
know this is pretty famous this is
pretty famous and so they hand the
camera over to uh the captain like they
take pictures I think they took um I
think it was six pictur pictures they
took and then they handed the camera
over to the captain and then they put it
into a safe so it's like nobody could
touch it apparently that's how the story
goes and then when they got to the port
they developed the film and the picture
which like I said is very famous in
paranormal circles looks like it shows
two guys faces um in the waves next to
the ship and according to all the crew
members they said it looked just like
the two guys that had died on the SS
water town now here's the interesting
thing about this let me show you the
picture that you're most uh that you're
most going to commonly see if you go to
like a paranormal website and it's this
yeah right here like these two little
faces like popping out the
waves so that's pretty creepy right like
it does kind of look like two faces so
that's and that's what the crew were
reporting that they had seen right and
that's the picture that they took of
allegedly now also allegedly um they
gave the picture to like a detective
agency and they looked at the picture
and they looked at the negatives and
everything like that and said that you
know oh it didn't look like it had been
faked or anything of that
nature now the thing that the crew
apparently reported they said when they
saw the faces off the side of the ship
they said usually what would happen the
faces would appear they'd be there for
like 5 to 10 seconds and then they would
like fade away they said the weird thing
about it though was that the faces
didn't seem to be moving with the ship
it's like they always seem to be the
same distance away from each other and
they always seem to be the same distance
away from the ship the heads were also
and I'm not sure if the crew reported
this but I'm going to say a little bit
about this in a minute but it's like the
heads looked like larger than normal
size heads okay so they're looking
over the railing yeah the first guy that
said he saw it was looking off the port
side of the ship and they see the faces
going with them in a
distance they're not passing them no the
faces are following them kind of but
it's they're big they're not within
they're not they're big but they it
seems like they're saying that it's not
like well the I mean the faces were only
there for like a few seconds at a time
it wasn't like they were just sitting
there okay but it's like it they said it
just seemed like the faces were just
kind of sitting there in the same place
and then they would kind of fade you
know what I'm saying then they would
come back yeah but like later like it
happened like over a few days that's
kind of what they reported
okay so yeah now interestingly so I was
um like I said they tested the negative
and everything like that it said
apparently they said it didn't look like
they was faking or anything like that um
they had taken six photos uh and that
was the only one that showed anything
unusual even though apparently they were
like hey the faces are there like take a
picture but it was only the one photo
where it came out in now I did find an
article online by somebody named Blake
Smith and they had apparently written an
article back in 2010 for the good old um
4an
times and his assertion was that he
thought the photo had been hoaxed but
not recently like back in
1925 and his one of the things he
pointed out is that the photo it's like
it does show the faces on the side of
ship like that but he's like if you saw
the photo like in full which I'm going
to show you in a minute cuz that's not
usually the one that they show you they
usually show you that close-up one like
that so you don't have any context so
it's like if you see this photo in full
like if those were like actual faces
they would be like a lot smaller like
you wouldn't even be able to see them
like these look like [__] giant ass
heads and he made the point that it's
like the crew didn't report giant ass
ghost heads floating on the side of the
thing I think they said they were like a
little bit bigger than normal but not as
big as they would have to be if you were
looking at the photo because here's the
thing like I said if you search ghosts
of the SS Watertown 99% of the pictures
that come up will be that one that I
just showed you like the closeup with
the
crops however if you look long enough
you will see the uncropped photo photo
here is the uncropped photo cuz it
looked low res yeah that is the
uncropped photo so look how if those are
heads yeah look how [__] big they'd
have to be yeah like that's way bigger
than a human head yeah you know what I
mean cuz look at the size of the ship
like in relation yeah to that and when
you see it from this angle it doesn't
look quite as it's yeah it still kind of
looks like faces but also the one if you
look at the far left that looks like a
face looking at you too oh yeah you're
right if you look at the Horizon at the
far
left the far left Horizon and go down a
little bit you look down I know about
about an inch I guess yeah you'll see
something looks like a [__] skull
screaming at you on the in the water
yeah next to the that wire there's a
wire yeah so who's that [__]
yeah what's
that you're just picking out
images yeah I mean your brain has the
ability Tock weird but it looks a lot
lot less impressive when you see it in
the not cropped version you know what I
mean yeah and then I can go in
underneath those faces and what is that
down there that that that's the water
what is I don't know exactly what I'm
say I see water splashing over the the
bow yeah okay I'm pretty sure that's
what that is you could find a lot of
faces down there underneath those other
faces too in the
water you know that's like what about
this one what about that one right you
know what I'm saying
the two eyes and the round mouth
yeah I'm trying to point at it but they
can't
see yeah but like I said if you look at
it long enough you can see other things
that look kind of like faces too yeah I
see I see a face right here yeah I do
too you know James said uh like I said
it's Shadows playing a trick on us and
our minds put faces there just like the
face on Mars yeah it seems a similar
like I said it is creepy looking but I I
don't think that's the real and so I
don't no cuz that's the thing like
apparently these guys like reported it
like that they'd seen these dudes faces
and then they just that was what gave
them the impetus to take a picture of it
but I don't know I there might be
another explanation for that because
like I said this happened in 1924 so it
was like a long time ago you know what I
mean well when you showed the first
picture I was like damn that's some low
resolution imagery well that's why
because it came from like a much larger
photo and the thing and yeah and it it
was taken in the 20s and like I said
it's I'm imagining that they probably
sourced that like from the newspaper
photo which was probably super shitty
20s still had good photographic
capabilities yeah they had good lenses
and stuff they just didn't have color
yet yeah so I was going like wow that's
awful
blurry you know you could see some crisp
photo photos from the 20s yeah you know
so yeah and that was not one of them no
well like I said these were just
apparently the story behind it was that
these are just dudes on a boat yeah that
were like oh man we' seen like our dead
crewmen floating out the side because
what a weird random thing to see like of
two guys that died on the ship and then
just like that they're just like there
just heads like floating in the [__]
water you know what I mean it's
crazy all right so uh so yeah so let's
talk about this one which I kind of feel
like is they think is maybe based on a
real thing but this is kind of like sort
of legendary like the Flying Dutchman
type of thing so this is the Ghost Ship
kuche I think I think I'm pronouncing
that correctly now this is uh again a
ghost ship this has its origins in the
in the uh chilo I guess it's chilo
mythology southern Chile so this is kind
of like a ship having to do with that
this is a fun story actually I'd never
heard of it heard of it before so it
goes by a bunch of different names the
Warlock ship which I like that uh or the
enchanted ship or barcoe I'm not really
sure what that means but that's another
name what's it called uh uh it's called
the kuche Marco iche Barco iche Barco
means
ship Barco means ship yeah what's that E
Yeah e ship I don't know what e means
but well yeah a barco is a ship okay
well so it's something something ship
something ship yeah well like I said
maybe it just means warlock ship or
something maybe cuz yeah we'll get into
that a minute so this is a ship there's
a bunch of different legends about this
now some of the legends about it are
kind of like cool they're all ghostly
but some of them are cool and some of
them are like you know and good and like
some of them are like evil you know what
I mean so this ship is supposed to um
sail along these canals like around this
area of Chile um super super fast now
another thing is that sometimes it seems
to be invisible but people seem to be
like able to sense its presence or hear
it you know what I mean so that's that's
another thing but then some people see
it too um it's supposedly more seen when
it's like foggy outside like you can see
the ship like cutting through the
fog uh it's supposed to look like an old
Spanish gallion uh it's supposed to be
white H it has three masks with five
sails on it and that when you see it it
has like lights coming out of every
single window on the ship so it's like
blazing with light also another thing
that people report is that whenever you
see it it sounds like there's a big
party going on in the ship like you can
hear people laughing and talking and
music and everything like
that now if Again The Story Goes that if
anybody goes near the ship like in a
regular ass ship then it will disappear
or become kind of like transparent and
your ship will just go right through it
you know what I
mean now like I said there's different
versions of this Legend now the oldest
version of The Legend which is actually
kind of the cool the nice
one so in this version of the legend the
ship is actually not really a ship but
actually like a living being of some
kind which is kind of weird but that's
kind of like the thing so this is
supposedly built by and I'm sure I'm
pronouncing this wrong but is L
mobo I guess which is like a like a sea
like in this
mythology so he built it for his kids
now his kids he had two daughters and
one son now one daughter uh was like a
mermaid and then the other daughter was
like a water Sprite type thing and then
he also had a son called pinky but I
don't know if he was like a magical
creature or anything like that he might
have been just a dude I don't really
know so apparently the story was that
the water Sprite and the Sun
would go and like search the oceans for
Sailors who had died at Sea like in
shipwrecks and stuff and then they would
bring their ghosts back to the
kuche and then they would bring the they
would bring them back to life and
basically they would just let them have
like Ghost Party ship like forever so it
was just like an immortal that's why
like people reported like seeing it and
it was just like sounded like there was
laughing and music and everything like
that because it was almost like sailor
Heaven it seemed like but like on a ship
you know what I mean so they just
brought them there like to party forever
which is kind of nice I thought thinking
more about you call it a Barco
Barco Barco doesn't mean ship navio
means ship Barco probably means
vessel maybe vessel yeah I know it's a
vessel or a boat I'm just trying to get
the exact English translation yeah it's
[__] funny baru
yeah any you Latin speakers [__] can
chime in I always thought Barco at
something like mouth or something like
that oh yeah okay so so I was kind of
close yeah bar I think means
vessel vessel or
boat yeah na VI is [__] a ship that's
a big [__] steel multi- deck like the
like the Titanic that would be on view
okay murder Hornet said he didn't see
any heads in that picture man it's cuz
you're tripping dude there were faces
well look like it did kind of look like
faces your mind can find faces and
anything it's kind of designed to do
that I look in the clouds I'll see a
face yeah if you want to see a face go
there's that's what that is right but
it's just well just like what's his name
it's like old boy said it's like the
face on Mars it's because yeah your
brain's doing it if you turn that image
upside down you don't see it as well and
now that they've taken like higher res
photos of it absolutely does not look
like a f anymore it just looks like a
[__] Hill which is what it is yeah
it's just a hill but I mean well I mean
human brains are I mean we evolved to
recognize faces so if something kind of
looks like a face then you're going to
make it look like a face that's just
kind of how your brain works everyone's
brain works like that that's what animal
animals know what a face is they look
right into your face right yeah yeah
that's what I mean so it's just like
it's not I think they can read
Expressions
too I would imagine yeah is she still
under there by the way no she's going
she left she left a little fck that was
so funny that she went under there she's
like I'm hiding they don't know where I
am she's like she's being sneaky but
yeah so so that was the nice version of
the story where the the mer it's
actually not the mermaid the water
Sprite and the sun they go out and
collect all the dead Sailors and they
like come back with us to the ship and
you can party forever and they're just
like okay that's awesome so I was like
well that's kind of nice but then of
course there's a lot of other not so
nice legends about the ship as well um
and in some of these Legends the ship is
actually uh controlled by an evil
Sorcerer And in this vers version the
ship actually kind of goes around
looking for live Sailors that it can
kind of entice onto the ship and then
[__] them up and then like make them
work on the ship like forever you know
what I mean so it's kind of like putting
them into like ghost servitude I guess
so yeah I mean and it'll abduct people
from Land too that's also another part
of the legend also I thought this was
kind of interesting so apparently
according to the
story um when they get these unfortunate
Sailors and put them on board the kuchi
they the sorcerer I guess fuses one of
their legs to their spine so they can't
walk anymore and they can't leave you
know what I mean so they're stuck on the
boat forever and they also get
transformed into a creature from Chilean
mythology called an
invunche which I guess these are kind of
like monsters that would normally like
guard the entrance to warlock caves cuz
I guess warlocks have caves that's where
they live point at it again
like where can you see it in i n v u n c
h e I think it's called I think it's
also called inun inan or inan I've seen
both spellings V is sometimes pronounced
B Yeah well yeah that's why so I've seen
like in in bun also but apparently I
don't know what these monsters look like
like in mythology but they apparently
hang out in front of warlock caves and
like keep people from going in because
that's just how they roll I guess that's
their function
so I had never heard of that kind of
monster before but apparently that's the
thing
so so apparently there are stories that
if you see the ship with the Warlock on
it you don't want to get your ass
kidnapped and like have your leg fused
to your thing and get turned into a like
a monster so you're what you were
supposed to do was you were supposed to
hide behind a particular type of tree
like it had to be a specific kind of
tree like a wineberry tree because I
guess that has like magical Properties
or or something so that was how you
would keep like the the evil sorcerer on
the ship from like seeing you you know
what I
mean um also there's another version of
the story which is actually the most new
the most modernish
version and this version of the story
the ship is being used by the Sorcerers
of
chilo this is a bunch of sorcerers and
this is their ship there's a little
little magical transport and they every
3 months they all get on the ship and go
around on a voyage to increase their
powers somehow now in this version the
ship is also was also made by the seag
God that I mentioned earlier and only
the crew can get on board the ship uh so
when some like a real person comes by it
like it's like and it like disappears
you know what I mean there were also
legends that you know whenever like the
ports around the area where the ship was
said to be seen
that some of the shop owners and stuff
like that would
like essentially make like f and
Bargains with the sorcerers on the ship
like for money or success or whatever so
whenever somebody in a village where in
This ship's territory I guess would like
suddenly come into a lot of money or
stuff or something like everybody would
think they were super sus because
they're just like oh my God you just
made a deal with like all the sorcerers
on the [__] ship you know what I mean
so it was it was that kind of [__] and
sometimes they would say that oh well
you're letting like all the ghost crew
like come in your house and party or
you're letting the sorcerers come in
your house and like do like black magic
rituals and stuff like that so like all
the people in the village would be like
really really upset about it there was
also in
1960 there was a big huge earthquake in
that area um and it was really bad there
was like [__] landid tsunamis fires
like the whole [__] deal now even
though this was like a really really bad
earthquake that caused like massive
destruction um there were a few houses
that were not affected at all and there
were stories going around that the
people that lived in those houses had
made deals with the sorcerers on the
ship like for their house not to get
[__] up so there was that too so it
was like a pretty strong like uh Legend
around the at the time um and also they
said that anybody that in the village
that had like a particular type of
anchor like outside their house or
something like that that was like a
signal to the sorcerers that they were
like cool with the sorcerers and they
wanted to like make a deal with them or
something like that so that was also
like a pretty common legend that they uh
you know had going on at the time now
there's also they they're kind of
thinking that this story might have come
from like I said legends about the
Flying Dutchmen which are pretty common
I think we talked about that on the last
show maybe or we did a show about it I'm
pretty sure um and that you know cuz
that was also supposed to have like you
know Undead people on it and also and
this was weird too because I looked up
and they said oh well maybe it's based
on um The Disappearance of a real ship
which was a Dutch ship which was called
the
colan but I looked that up and I
couldn't find because there's a
Wikipedia page called uh you know list
of missing ships or ships lost at sea or
whatever like they don't know where they
are and I couldn't find it on there that
doesn't mean it's like not a real thing
it's weird because when I was looking it
up there's a ship that's called that the
colan that is I guess like floating
around it's not like a ship ship but
it's like it's pretty small but you can
kind of like track where it's at like on
a website and stuff and I was just like
well that's kind of weird but yeah so so
I don't know if that Dutch
ship really went missing but that's
something that I see a lot that maybe
that's where the story of this came from
but I don't know if that was a real ship
or not I couldn't really find any
evidence that that was a real ship so
you know what I mean um however like
Skeptics again have said that probably
uh the Legends existed prior to that
like about the ship and everything but
what they probably did was that
Smugglers would um kind of play up the
Legends so that they could like do
sketchy [__] like without anybody
knowing what they were doing you know
what I mean like it's like oh my God
it's the [__] Ghost Ship you know
what I mean which that's pretty clever
if that's what they were doing but yeah
so I don't really know if this is like I
said it's mostly legendary so I don't
really know if there's like sightings of
it I imagine there are because people
have said like described it and stuff
but so there's that but I thought that
was kind of a fun story I like the idea
of a bunch of warlocks on a ship I also
liked the idea of like the ghost party
ship I thought that was kind of nice
warlocks on a ship that sounds like a
Lovecraft it does Lovecraft would have
that
[__] yeah Arabic Arabic and Mesopotamian
warlocks on a ship trying to bring back
some kind of ocean God yeah [__] Deon
or something it does sound very love
crafty and now that I think about it
yeah well some of those Lovecraft
stories had you know the sea was a big
element in there ports [__] cuz he
seemed to be like super scared of
seafood man see like seafood he didn't
like anything have to do with the ocean
and people that were worked on the ocean
because they [__] they weren't all the
same
race you might Horrors yeah you might
have to be working with people of other
races when you're out there in the sea
you know that's not that's what he was
thinking yeah he was scared of other
white people so you know he was scared
of anybody that wasn't him yeah love
crap was [__] funny it wasn't him and
his family although to his credit he got
better he did get better he got better
as he got older he he realized he kind
of got over it he realized that other
people weren't out to get him that he
had fans I mean he had problems yeah
let's let's not say that um he he was
xenophobic oh big time like if anybody I
mean if you have the word xenophobia
there should be a picture of H car after
like right yeah if you didn't speak
English then [__] there was something
wrong with you if you if you weren't of
English descent there was something
wrong with you like you [__] if you were
German or Irish descent oh [__] yeah he
did not like that no he didn't like
anybody he just thought everybody was
just like R to his credit though he he
to his credit though he started dating a
Jewish girl they got married for a
little while got married yeah and he she
actually like moved him to New York City
yeah she she brought him out of a shell
a lot I will say she was a writer too
it's old thing you know got people want
to cancel Lovecraft because he was he's
racist he didn't stay that way you know
what I mean he was young too and he was
he was he was he was weird he was a
nerdy dude very much shut in he wasn't
worldly and that's really his xenophobia
is what caused him to write all that
[__] bizarre [__] that's what made
him good if he was a normal dude you
would have forgotten about him he was
just a weird dude yeah I think that the
reason that he came up with that crazy
[__] was because he was scared of
everything and
yeah so everybody was like a monster to
him yeah and he was scared that God
hated you and that God hated him so he's
right that yeah in his in his mind gods
did hate you I kind of feel like he was
one of the first he might he might not
have been the first dude but he was one
of the first dudes to write about the
horror of an indifferent universe or
like not even indifferent but like one
that actively wanted you dead or like
wanted to destroy you or just thought
you were scum yeah yeah there were gods
that thought you were scum and they were
or that you were just completely
insignificant like like an antill or
something yeah it was a Pantheon there
wasn't one God there was multiples of
Waring Gods none of them created you and
they all hated you or didn't care which
is a pretty frightening concept you know
what I mean world he lived in you can
see well that's what I mean and if he
hadn't been so weird and had such like
mental problems he might not have come
up with that stuff yeah yeah had he been
a normal guy he never written in his cuz
I don't think I would have come up with
anything like that because it's like I'm
weird but I'm not that [__] weird no
dud dudes dudes and just women that come
up with [__] cool art they all got
issues well I would argue that it you
know it the the best artists and writers
and stuff you kind of have to have
something to matter with you yeah you
kind of have to something to matter well
it's a nerdy Endeavor okay although and
Lovecraft and we're getting off this
topic but I just wanted to [__] give
a shout out to Lovecraft Lovecraft
invented the concept of a
universe he invented the MCU there was a
Lovecraft Universe filled with [__]
monsters and gods other writers got in
on it yeah and people and he had he had
a huge fan base who thought that maybe
he was telling the truth that he was
somehow the Oracle of a [__] some
kind of an occult truth you know that he
was somehow in contact with these things
he said he was scared of his [__] one of
the things he was scared of most was his
fans he thought his fans were terrifying
well I can see that because they thought
a lot some of them thought that what he
was talking about was real I would be
scared of those kind of people too not
going to lie yeah if I wrote something
and just like pulled it out of my ass
and made it up and then suddenly I had
like all these obsessive people that
were like talking to me like it was real
I would absolutely be terrified of those
people so I can't blame him for that so
I'm going to give Lovecraft the credit
for in creating the concept of a
universe yeah like the MCU or DC
Universe you know he had his own yeah
way ahead of his time oh yeah big time
and like I said I'm not really sure
because I know there were like some
other people doing some [__] like that
like Lord duny and stuff but I don't I
he was kind of the first one to like
kind of codify it I feel like one of the
greatest products to ever come out of
Massachusetts
Boston and his and he's um he was from
Providence Rhode Island Rhode Island
yeah but I think he lived in Boston
though didn't he uhuh oh okay I thought
first for some reason I thought he lived
in Boston [__] man he's even buried in
Rhode Island it says I am Providence
with his thing on it like he's very not
far though I know but he's very
associated with Providence RH Island
that's where he's from all right but um
but yeah rhod Island then yeah Rhode
Island yeah I used to go to [__]
Providence they had a good goth club in
Providence my sister used to go there
she really liked it yeah I've never been
to Providence I was kind of interested
to go just because of the Lovecraft
connection we used to we used to and
it's not a city you hear a lot about No
we would take breaks from from man
raised in Boston and we go to Providence
I'm trying to remember what the name of
that club was I think it was called Club
hell I think it what it was I think it
was called Club hell if I remember
correctly was pretty good they were
smaller town Goths so you would show up
there and they [__] you're like wow
you know what I mean [__] they just
wow you guys are impressive you guys are
from Boston that kind big city
[__] yeah big city
[__]
right even though even though Providence
was not a small City no it's not still
pretty big too it's just you don't
really hear a lot you don't hear about
it it's not famous city like it's not a
super famous city but yeah that's where
Lovecraft was from yeah I liked
Providence yeah it's like Lovecraft is
very associated with Providence and just
like Po is very associated with
Baltimore you know what I mean yeah I
can't think about it huh when I went
there I showed I got there I didn't know
how long it would take to drive there
the first time I went there so I ended
up about an hour early the club hadn't
opened and I'm [__] goth out like
[__] crazy you know what I mean
[__] I look like [__] lat or some
[__] and I'm looking around say Where's
the safe place to go [__] so I saw
another goth that was getting ready to
go and I says man I want to get a drink
before the clubs opens and I said
where's the safe place to go he goes oh
right there man go because that's an old
Queen bar [__] go in there man yeah
[__] that's always the safe it was
like an old man bar was like old gay
dudes yeah like so they're not going to
[__] with you about the way you're
dressed D you can't go to a jog bar
especially not back in these days this
is the 90s well I wouldn't go to a jock
bar now no so I go into the queen bar I
go into the queen bar man and [__] I
get [__] [__] red carpet treatment
didn't even buy a drink just you know
old guy he's in his 60s you know would
you mind having a drink with me and I
says well you know I'm straight I'm just
ready to he goes no no no it's okay so
you know so sat it down had a drink with
the old dude [__] I was getting
drinks kept coming and I had to go
listen gu because I was like 25 at the
time so you know I'm like listen guys I
really appreciate this but I have to go
to this other club and you guys are
trying to get me loaded and they're
laughing They're laughing you trying to
get me loaded I got I got to get out of
here I can't drink all this [__] man
[__] I'll be staggering out of here
this you got you dirty [__] and
they're all [__] laugh no I was a
center of attention there at that place
but I had makeup on you know [__]
pale skin and [__] gol eyes Shadow on
and
[__] FR black frock coat and I was
[__] had black [__] tight PVC
pants and [__] kneei doc Martins and
[__] cocktail gloves and [__] all
kinds of [__] fangs I had fangs in
[__] black
hair I had a fan too remember a [__]
fan oh nice I had a fan like right out
of [__] 17 man you need to do that
[__] again bad it was back in the day
had a fan you need to you probably get
need to get bigger sizes now cuz your
arms are
enormous that would look cool I I've
seen pictures of you from back cuz that
was before I met you yeah but I've seen
you were very old school like I really
liked that everything was retro 1700s
and
1800s mixed with fet
bondage gear mixed in with it I always
liked that that look yeah well like I
said that's what you got to do if you
don't got a goth bar you go to the gay
bar M don't it wasn't just a gay bar it
was a queen bar yeah it was old guy old
gays it was all [__] stuffy and [__]
with Brandy sniffers and [__] you know
it wasn't like yeah drinking brandy and
[__] yeah they had [__] Zack would
have loved it they have [__] pictures
of Tom Cruz and his [__] underwear
from [__] Risky Business and that
risky
no what was name yeah it was risky yeah
and [__] [__] like that up all right
I'm going to ding it a little cuz come
on but it was like that old school bar
with [__] brass [__] railings on
bronze railings and [__] it was like
that yeah it was a queen bar yeah that's
pretty awesome yeah like I said you
never you can't be G that you can't go
to I feel hot as [__] going in there
well I imagine yeah it was like what
happens when a [__] 20-year-old girl
shows up the [__] club and the
[__] you know it's nothing but old
men in there of course they you know was
like was like that old men and old
ladies yeah old like that
yeah yeah it's like if you can't like I
said if you can't find a go don't go to
a jock bar don't go to a normie bar
don't go to sports bar nothing like that
they will not understand any of that
they will not understand not back in
those days go to the go to the gay bar
go to the biker or the biker bar yeah
you probably You' probably be all right
at a biker part yeah they they're like
yeah whatever
yeah they just got shittier music I just
saw said man I want to go get something
to drink for the club where's the safe
place to go go right there man it's old
Queen bar gay bar [__] okay
yeah like I said that's that's a safe
you can go there nothing bad's going to
happen like I said you go to a jock bar
someone's going to [__] with you yeah
guarante they want to fight guarantee it
they want to fight and what reason why
they're going want to fight is cuz the
girls are going to show you too much of
attention well yeah they don't like that
yeah they don't like that and they don't
get it so uh no yeah we would never go
to places like that when we were younger
not in those days I don't do it now I
don't even like walking past them to be
honest because you always get [__] like
just even walking past them like the
people walking outside it was always
like [__] sketchy yeah you know what
I mean but yeah all right so I only have
one more story and it's kind of short
okay and then we can talk about whatever
you want talk about going get something
to eat after I pee we're g to finish up
that Thai food with noodles oh we still
got some yeah I got enough for both of
them nice all right all right so the
last story I'm going to talk about is
the Palatine light and speaking of Rhode
Island this happens in Ro Rhode Island
you know since we were just so there's a
nice
segue so apparently uh residents of
Block Island which is a little island
like in Rhode Island you know what I
mean uh usually between Christmas and
New Year's like the week between
Christmas and New Year's um you see this
really creepy light which is supposed to
be the this ghost ship called the
Palatine and people have been reported
seeing this for hundreds of years uh
sometimes the light is really little
sometimes it's really big like it
actually looks like a ship and like kind
of looks like a like a flaming torch
type of
situation now a lot of people have seen
this uh Ghost Ship but they do know that
this is actually based on a real story
now we don't know all of the details of
exactly what happened after but this is
actually like a documented story so the
palentine light story is based on
something that happened back in
so there was this big British ship
called the princess
Augusta and it left uh roddam in the
Netherlands and there was the captain's
name was George long and there were 14
crew members and on the ship uh the
passengers there were 240 immigrants
mainly German immigrants and they were
going to um the United
States now the reason that this story
eventually ended up being called the
Palatine light was because the
passengers were all pal uh palatines
which were uh you know in the 18th
century were uh immigrants from the
middle R uh area of uh Germany so they
were actually heading to Philadelphia
where there were some other uh there
some already like German uh you know
areas there that they could kind of
settle in so that's where they were
going
to now uh the princess
gusta pretty much as soon as it set out
I don't know if as soon as it set out
but like all kind of during the voyage
um kind of a shitty Voyage I'm going to
say uh the weather was real bad there
was a lot of Storms and stuff like that
at some point in the voyage the water
supply was
contaminated and 200 of the passengers
and seven members of the crew uh
including the captain died from this
contaminated water
so since the captain had died from this
disease the first mate whose name was
Andrew Brooke he took
over now there was a bunch of storms the
ship was pushed off course and it was so
off course that the ship was basically
like floating around for three months uh
of you know varying storms trying to get
back to like where they were at you know
what I mean this is 1730 so they didn't
really have like a lot of you
know uh so because they were out much
much longer than anticipated obviously
they started um running out of
food um now later
on according to later depositions from
the crew members after the whole [__]
show like took place they said that the
first mate who had taken over as the
captain he was actually making the
passengers pay for their food because it
was running out you know what I mean
which seems kind of a dick move but okay
um now he tried to go like a different
way like from Rhode Island to
Philadelphia but the storms kept pushing
them all around and finally the ship
wrecked there was a snowstorm and it
ended up wrecking at a place called
Sandy Point at um a couple days after
Christmas of
1738 now the people that survived the
wreck um they did do some depositions of
the surviving crew members and they said
the first mate uh was again a real dou
not only did he make people pay for the
you know rations which were dwindling
but he also said that uh the first mate
and the crew what was left of the crew
they had actually jumped in the boat and
rode to shore like while all the
passengers were still on the ship like
after it wrecked they're just like bye
you know again dick move seems like a
dick move um now apparently the people
who lived on Block Island and saw the
Shipwreck happen um did kind of Step Up
and like try to help the people and like
get them off the ship and get their [__]
you know uh you know off the boat and
everything like that uh 20 of them had
died after the wreck from various causes
and they did like bury them on the
island uh and there is apparently still
a grave marker there uh called the
Palatine Graves that was are put there
like later
on now what happened after the wreck no
one's real clear about it now even
though it would seem that the crew
members were jerks uh and didn't help
the people get off the boat just left
all the passengers there like f good
luck you know what I mean so it was that
but they um weren't charged for whatever
reason uh they made it to the mainland
and most of the surviving passengers
like I said 20 of them did die um they
kind of made it to them but they don't
really know what happened after that
they said they know two of the survivors
uh stayed on the island and like just
settled down there and lived there for a
long time um now the ship they're not
entirely sure happened to it um they
said that maybe like some accounts said
that it was unsalvageable and they
pushed it out to see to sink or uh it
was set on fire U you know to Scuttle it
and then it would subsequently sank
there are also stories that there was
one woman who went crazy on the ship her
name uh is Mary
vanderlin and she they tried to get her
off the ship and she wouldn't like she
refused to to come so she went down with
the ship cuz she just wouldn't come with
them like they couldn't rescue her now
they did so and that's another story
it's like a lot of times they like you
can still hear her screaming and all
that so that's probably part of the
ghost
story so um they now they have looked
for the remains of this ship they do
know that there was that sh I mean the
ship was a real ship and [__] like that
but there's like not sure what exactly
happened to it or like where it ended up
so they have looked for the wreckage but
they haven't found it yet now they're
also because it's like it's perfectly
possible that the ship wasn't sunk and
that like it was repaired and then went
on to other things so that could have
happened
too but the thing about it is that
there's um this particular area Block
Island of in Rhode Island is um
geographically kind of um it sort of had
a reputation at the time as a place
where people would wreck ships on
purpose like to loot them you know what
I mean I don't know how uh accurate that
reputation is but it did have that
reputation for a while crash on rocks or
something yeah like what they said that
you know and and you know I don't want
to disparage like you know the people
are long dead but I'm just like saying
people Black Island back then there was
kind of a reputation that it's like they
would like put false beacons up and
stuff like that so people would come
there and like crash on the ship and
then they take all their [__] you know
what I mean and there were also rumors
that they killed the people on the ship
too like I said I don't know if that's
true but there were kind of like rumors
going around about that now because of
this
story um Legends kind of grew up around
this uh wreck which apparently did
happen and it be kind of became this
Ghost Ship story like I said so
everybody like they would see the ship
with all these lights on it sometimes
you'd hear this woman that supposedly
went mad and wouldn't come off the ship
like you could hear her screaming and
all this other kind of stuff so it's
like people have reported seeing that um
also I think something that helped this
story a lot was that the very famous
poet John Greenleaf Whittier in 1867 he
wrote a poem about it and it was called
The Wreck of the Palatine like I said
the ship wasn't actually called the
Palatine it was actually called what did
I say it was called the the Augusta or
whatever it was called what did I say it
was called Princess Augusta it's called
the princess gusta I was I was almost
right um but over the years it became
called the Palatine because of the
people that were on it you know what I
mean were palatines so that's what they
called it so he wrote a poem uh called
The Wreck of the Palatine because you
know how poets and songwriters love the
[__] shipwreck stories so he wrote a
poem about it and that's why everybody
knows it it's Palatine right because
that's what he called it um so I so I
don't know like what happened in the end
of it they didn't find uh like I said
the first mate and the crew despite how
dickish they were they weren't charged
with anything and they didn't get
punished for anything um and as far as I
know the graves are still there of the
people that I believe it was 20 people
that like died in the wreck or died
after the wreck and they like buried
them on the island and that's still
there but to this day particularly
between Christmas and New Year's uh
people will say that they see this ship
lighted out in out in the water like off
of Block Island and it's because of that
shipwreck so there's
that so there's that kak says y'all look
awesome as always happy to see you guys
live again happy Halloween month thank
you very much yeah yeah you haven't been
around in a while haven't been around
could have a bad yeah Camp guy says the
water that we drink here on Earth is
recycled from the piss of dinosaurs from
a 100 million years ago I mean that yeah
that probably is the case it was all
[__] comets and [__] that hit us from
the kyber belt all the water it's all
brought here all the water water water
is
common common in space but it's
frozen frozen hard as rock out there yep
common carbon is
common well yeah it's everywhere that's
why hydrocarbons are so common it's
everywhere yeah Danny Rowling said Tom
Cruz did a good job with the film The
Others which there should be a sequel
with a different but same Wait a Minute
Tom Cruz wasn't in the others was he the
others which one was the others that was
isn't that if the one you talking about
is that like the ghost story no no no
that's the other I think that was the
other that was from the 70s Tom Cruz
probably wasn't even well he was born
but I thought maybe there's a reboot no
okay there was a movie called The Others
yeah it was a ghost story like an old
school ghost story and it came out in
two I want to say 2001 2002 Nicole
Kidman was in it uh Christopher eckleson
was in it it's great if you haven't seen
it like if you love old school ghost
stories which I do it's one of my
favorite like old school ghost stories
it's super creepy heard of it I saw it
yeah oh it's good oh it's good we should
see it then I don't know if you I mean
like I said do you like if you like [__]
like the changeling I or something like
that like you'd probably be into it it's
very very old school I think it's set
during is it set during World War I or
World War II now I can't remember but um
because I haven't seen it a long time I
actually wouldn't mind rewatching it
because I really like it I thought it
was super creepy it's and oh and it's
kind of like you know what it reminds me
of the Innocence yeah okay if you like
the Innocence you know like turn the
screw um it's kind of like that but cuz
it's her and her two kids and like the
husband is away at War and they're
allergic to
light it's a whole thing but it's really
good it's really creepy I like it a lot
but Tom Cruz is not in it I don't think
not that I remember like I said I
remember yeah Tom Cruz is not in that
[__] movie I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know what you're
talking about
um oh okay so oh Danny rling said he
produced the film with his wife at the
time okay so he okay so he was married
to Nicole kimman at the time that's what
you're talking because I was like Tom
Cruz is pretty is not in that movie he
would have ruined it oh stop it no he
would have because I'm defend it's not
but yeah but you've never seen the movie
he's in the short man it's not the kind
of movie that he is good in let's put it
that way it's just if you see it you'll
know what I'm talking about this is a
Tom Cruz movie starring Tom Cruz as Tom
Cruz
all right I kind of feel like he should
make that movie that's all of yeah Tom
Cruz in a Tom Cruz movie as Tom Cruz
playing Tom Cruz sometimes I forget
directed by Tom Cruz produced by Tom
Cruz edited by Tom Cruz edited by Tom
Cruz grip score by Tom Cruz yeah yeah
hell
yeah catered by Tom Cruz yeah that's
right that's right right he even made
the [__] s Tom Cruz hey I already
made that
joke yeah best boy Tom Tom Cruz that's
right what exactly does the best boy do
I don't know I mean I you would think
like like Zach might know or somebody
that like Works in film I know what is a
best boy I mean I guess I could look it
up on on Google I just that just
occurred to me right now because I
always see that in the credits I'm like
what the [__] does that person do talk
all the [__] you want about Tom Cruz man
[__] he has never failed never failed
to to deliver I was talking [__] about
it I was just saying I don't think he he
does that that's what he does right
there I don't think he would have been
good when you see when I see a Tom Cruz
movie he gives me Tom Cruz that's it you
love Tom Cruz yeah no he's good you'd
let Tom Cruz P he doesn't have a what
what what you'd let Tom Cruz Peg you no
hell no hell no hell no I'm just trying
to I'm just trying to see never do that
that's out ethics that's out ethics man
yeah you got a point there yeah he's he
have to go through auditing afterwards
and [__] then they'd never let but
see that's how that's how they might get
around it just like the Catholics do
they can do whatever [__] up [__] they
want as long as they go to confession
right so I kind of feel like yeah but
they record it if and use it against you
later well he doesn't seem to be like
want to leave so he doesn't seem to be
that worried about like all the
blackmail stuff I'm sure that they have
on him yeah you know I don't think they
have that much on the only if they have
anything on him it's going to be Casting
Couch
[__] yeah that you know that's probably
if they have something it's going to be
that yeah that's what that's kind of
what I was imagining yeah Casting Couch
[__] Bryce says Tom Cruz can Peg me
LOL
see there you go damn see other people
like it BRAC it damn Zach says the best
boy see I thought you I knew you would
know uh is kind of an assistant in the
electrical department helps with the
lights and generation sh okay that I
wonder why they call it the best boy
though that seems like a weird
traditional I know but it's just it
seems a little um disparaging a little
no I don't know no you're reading
minimizing that's just like fog horn I'm
the best boy it's just like it's just
like fog horn Leghorn run around going
say come here boy come here tell you
something and crackers of that era and I
was I'm old enough to remember crackers
when I was a little kid Mississippi not
like Ritz crackers but like Mississippi
real Mississippi crackers all right
[__] they were old men when I was a
little boy but I remember they called
everybody boy everybody everybody they
called everybody boy and they called
everybody son I'll tell you what son you
know that that's exactly dad [__] boy
you know it just like saying man or
something I didn't mean anything Ray
says it's not gay if he does that
because he Tom Cruz he can do whatever
he wants yeah so but boy but uh in Old
in the olden days boy didn't mean
anything would you kiss Tom Cruz who you
no no no that's out of
Ethics no I'm just saying in a
hypothetical situation if he was down no
you wouldn't no I thought you loved him
though what does that got to do with
love that's that's sluttery
that like I said I'm just curious I like
asking you uncomfortable question to see
what these women in their fantasies I
[__] love Tom Cruz no I don't like I
I do not find Tom Cruz attractive all I
like his work I I I appreciate his
dedication but I'm just wondering they
gave him a lot of [__] because he jumped
up on Oprah's couch and uh and he's in
Scientology but had that been anybody
else he been all right yeah well they
just they're coming down on time you
know yeah he's diabolical according to
people inside yeah according to people
inside catology he's diabolical I see
that but it's because Scientology is a
[__] paramilitary type situation and
a lot of people that have rank in the
military come across as diabolical
because they're just trying to get jobs
done I just think it's funny that he
takes that seriously but I guess they
have to you know I always thought that
was kind of funny too I'm like you
realize like some dude just made that
all up right it's a paramilitary cult
UFO cult basically trying to make a
[__] into a Jedi that is it just
it makes me laugh when they talk about
it so seriously into a wizard trying to
make into a wizard but I mean to be fair
I kind of think that about a lot of
religions when everybody's like just
very very dead serious like talking
about like just the the little ins and
outs of like obviously Fantastical and
it just like why are we are we're
grown-ups can we not like just talk it's
it's kind of a rough religion it's it's
it's a totalitarian Society you know um
I don't really approve of How It's run
but they are doing what Elon hover tell
told them to do pretty much although
according to everybody that I've heard
and all the Scientologist High rcking
Scientologist even with Freddy Prince
Freddy Prince he his [__] he was like
one of the top Auditors and he was like
one of the only black guys in in
Scientology and he only saw elron Hub
once all right they said he was a
[__] weird looking old man in the
back of the a [__] limine with his
[__] big old fish lip his big long
fingernails and [__] yeah you see look
like Colonel Sanders back there Colonel
Sanders was way better looking gave him
a mini14 as a gave him a mini14 rifle as
a [__] as a present
but eron Hub was liked by the cult
members he was a good guy uh by and by
all accounts he was a good guy he was
weird but one of the weird things about
him things that made him different than
any other cult leader is that he was not
sexually abusing any of the women that
we know of yeah no they would have they
would have said something you'd think he
was surrounded by these little cabin
girls and shorts and [__] no they they
had they had [__] some of those girls
said who left the church who left the
church said no he was not sexual
strangely enough maybe he was one of
asexual people yeah like was 99.99% of
all dudes that start Cults do it so they
can like [__] underage girl yeah and get
money yeah well that too yeah those two
things that's really the only reason not
just underage girls other people's wives
yeah that's like the only reason that
they start a call like money and [__]
girls they probably shouldn't yeah
that's pretty much the only two reasons
evidently he wasn't like that and he'd
get get up on the [__] bow of the
ship with everybody and [__] tell
them what was happening on other planets
and point at the stars and [__] tell
these [__] stories all night long and
people [__] loved it so the cult
liked him so when he died he got
replaced by David mavage and he was kind
of a [__] he ruled the place with an
Iron Fist and didn't he didn't know much
about scientology per se just knew about
the business and the dayto day he was
more ruthless and Tom Cruz was his
friend kind of they said that David
mcavin talked [__] about Tom Cruz behind
his back treat him like a chump that
sounds like something David mcav they're
both short guys they're a short man
Mafia things you know what I mean short
guys get
along but but evident Miss cavage just
[__] talking bad talking bad about
him like he's a sap you know like I said
that sounds like something he
[__] he because he just seems
like a giant gaping [__] yeah uh
Bryce says maybe hubard was impotent I
was thinking yeah possibly he did have
children but that was from his earlier
years it could he may have not been able
to get it up maybe yeah his health
wasn't that good so that could have been
what it is yeah so it's maybe he just
kind of like slowly lost interest or
just was like well I can't do anything
so he
had wives and girlfriends but evidently
he only kept his activity with
them which like I said is crazy although
he did throw his wife under the bus so
that's not cool yeah made her go to
prison for made her go to prison for
what he did we're got changing this
subject well like I said we were done
with the ghost yeah yeah we're talking
about the best boy thing Zach said back
in the day the people rigging up
lighting electricity or cameras would
yell out for a bit of assistance by
asking someone to send them their best
boy yeah so that's where it came your
best guy yeah yeah you think best guy
would be a better well was different the
word boy implies like a child which I
don't want a child working on the
electrical on my movie just saying well
they may have been young yeah but I'm
just saying they may like I said I'm
thinking like of a 5-year-old here I'll
do that they might have been teenagers
when they when that term first started
well look at
infantry it comes from infant which is
like a [__] French word it means
boys because and in their French days
when all that was going on the average
age is probably 15 16 well alal means
children yeah just generally yeah go
garon means boy yeah yeah well it me
they were referring to children or boys
kids yeah child
labor yeah the good old days well armies
start off with child soldiers yeah I
know that's usually how it starts
they're the best they're good at it
because they they don't have a concept
of
death I mean yeah yeah those little
African Child soldiers were [__]
deadly they were
effective Danny rling said uh Jenny is
there any chance for Friday's show you'd
be able to do a brief history of horror
films like what was an option for
tonight's show uh just because that
would have been an Illuminating show you
know what I was thinking I was thinking
if we don't do it Friday night if I
don't have time to like put it together
I was thinking of doing it as a video
and putting it up on Halloween because I
still want to do it like if I have time
to do it then I will because I really
want to do it too so we'll either talk
about it on Friday night or I'll make a
video like I'll make a video and put it
up and try to get it up on Halloween
okay so I do I do actually want to do it
because but it's a it's crazy because I
just saw that um cin Massacre put one up
there was like history of horror movies
but what he did was he put up he just
like did a brief thing talking about a
movie like all through the decades like
it would just be like 2 minutes or
something and then like he just compiled
them all together so it's like hey today
we're talking two minutes about Nas
veratu or today we're talking about
Frankenstein or whatever so it was fun I
watched it it ended up being like an
hour and 15 minutes or something like
that but it's like I kind of just wanted
to do like one long video about it
Zach's ask is that Zach asking me doing
Elton impersonation you talking about
Elton John when did I do an Elton John
impersonation I don't remember you doing
an El John unless we talked about it
like cuz I know we saw that movie Rocket
Man a long time ago I never did an Elton
John impression yeah I don't remember
you ever singing like Elton John I
remember you singing like danig a lot I
remember you singing like Roy Orbison a
lot yeah um who else do you sing like
you can sing like Andrew eldrid from
Sisters of Mercy you can do that little
bit of David Bowie yeah you can kind of
do David Bo sometimes oh he met elron
Huard oh Metron
H it kind of sounds like the BTK boy
that way I
think
you got to like this you got to purse
your lips out like we have to
understand that on regular sea was an
entire race of creatures that were had
evolved to be in a cast
system that was totally focused around
the production of ice
cream chocolate ice cream strawberry ice
cream vanilla ice cream although they
didn't call them that and they didn't
come from the same sources they had
their equivalents of those on regular
sea and whole armies would be formed to
fight over who had the best flavor of
ice
cream so one day they invented nuclear
weaponry destroyed each other
using
airplanes I'm not
going that's like something that's like
some El that that soundss like some [__]
he would have come up not going to lie
they invented
radiation radioactive ice cream they
invented it but no they invaded
radiation all right keep talking for a
second cuz I got I got to pee I'm done
we're g to shut it down shut down see
look look at how look at how she does I
don't want to
talk man I gotta go [__] cook I got
to cook she wants she wants she likes
the show to last forever no I don't
let's see what's going
on NE said ice cream yeah
yeah then once they United the planet
after the after their world wars they
combined all three flavors into a single
flavor called what we would call today
Neapolitan so that's why I've delivered
it to you all here on the end of our
ship here on the free
winds and and as a gift from me and
Scientology you will all be raised one
step forward on the bridge so you're now
OT whatever OT level you are now I'm
going to add one more OT level to
you which me being Source I'm now
ot2 just
kidding all
right Bryce says the Mari Ed boy and
girl all the time I accidentally talked
that way to an American and she let me
have it yeah yeah they're sensitive
they're [__] too
sensitive where that came from was a
bunch of crackers in the South and
crackers just called everybody boy boy
or son cuz they were you know people
don't know what a Kracker is sorry I was
dying cracker was cracker was just a an
old dude that dressed up Cracker Jack
and pretended like he had a job but he
really didn't have a job he was kind of
like the white version of a pimp except
he didn't even have any hoes he sat on a
[__] porch porch he sat on a a porch
pimp yeah he's a porch sat on a
porch Colonel Sanders was a cracker that
that's exactly how they looked I
remembered them they'd have different
little outfits that they'd wear and they
would act important and when anything
well hold on hold on now son hold on you
know we can't have this here CH with a
ch ch they say [__] like that you know
and then if they got real famous for
being a cracker they could get a a job
with the county and be become like a in
Kentucky they became a Kentucky Colonel
and that's what Colonel Sanders colel
yeah he's not like a colonel in the
military he was just a colonel because
that was just AAL he was so [__]
honorific that they gave people just for
yeah and really all they did is they got
a paycheck every month for being a
cracker and they would just why can't I
get that huh why can't I get that and
they would show up to groundbreaking
ceremonies they'd cut the [__]
ribbons put the white suit on and
and on this here on this cheer day we
shall commemorate you know the breaking
of the ground of the new bank that we're
GNA build right here in this town right
here today you know you know okay y'all
and then they have like a you know
[__] some beauty queen back there you
know [__] with her sash [__] wav
and they take a picture they put that in
the newspaper you know the local
newspaper that's all that was yeah you
didn't actually have to like do anything
no but neither did beauty queens
well yeah that's not a job either no but
they take pictures of and pretend like
they had a job yeah yeah that's all it
was white people ran a show you know was
in the South you know if black people
ran a show then they' just they they'd
have their own equivalence of that
they'd have some d a pimp he didn't have
a hoe you know yeah yeah we're gonna put
the bank here F it'd be the same thing
you know there was no difference really
between white people and black people of
the Old South they were pretty much the
same the only difference was the color
and the family recipes of the food they
basic but they ate basically the same
thing yeah there a lot it was the same
English a lot of ionics is actually just
Southern stuff you know just that black
people moved North and they took it with
them but all my friends all my dad's
friends if you were to hear them over
the phone and that's a generation older
than me they're old men now if you heard
any of my dad's friends over the phone
you think they were black they're not
though they're white they just very deep
south
Mississippi
Zach says damn now I want mint chocolate
chip ice cream and put some peanut
butter on it I don't think I've ever put
peanut butter on mint chocolate chip I
have melted peanut butter and put it on
other
flavors like just regular chocolate chip
or vanilla I'm going to give you example
who my dad's friends my dad and and and
my my dad sounds like and all his
friends sound like if you go on YouTube
you go Google go search the Hodge twins
there two twins they're marine guys
they're light-skinned kind of black guys
they're from they're from Alabama deep
parts of Alabama my dad and all his
friends sound just like that if you
heard them over the phone you would know
what color they were you think they were
black and and Jenny will tell you when I
start talking to my dad over the phone I
just get more more like that at 10
minutes into it I'm totally into that
dialect and I don't think about it it's
just
subconscious I have to hear it if I hear
it then I just respond that
way
well a lot of times if you're around
people that talk in a certain way you're
going to start talking like that yeah
you know what I mean yeah well my I grew
up around a guy who sounded like that
yeah you know well [__] I lived in the
UK for a little while and I came back
and everybody said I sounded funny
sounded British yeah so you know and I
didn't mean to pick it up I didn't like
I wasn't trying to be like Madonna or
nothing like that I was just kind of but
I'll even use expr I didn't realize it
is a different dialect though I'll just
without thinking about it use
Expressions you know and words that they
would understand another person wouldn't
understand like nobody know only
somebody in Mississippi know what a
Godly Nipper is you don't know what a
goly Nipper is I've heard that word
though
yeah golly Nipper is
a mosquito or a mosquito hawk anything
that flies and it's we have another word
for that but I can't remember what it is
cuz my grandfather used to call him
something but I can't remember what the
word was but it was something similar to
that yeah that's why I said I'd kind of
heard something like that before all
right so guess it's almost 10:00 so
we're going to wrap it up we're going to
go eat some Tai Curry that Tom made the
other day yeah which sounds really good
yeah and we might find some fun [__] to
watch okay all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by thanks for
super chats as always uh we are going to
be back again on Friday night for our
really fun Sidetrack show like I said we
might be doing history of horror movies
but I might just make a separate video
for that to put up on Halloween cuz I
wanted to do something for Halloween so
I was thinking maybe I would do that if
I have time to like write it all out and
everything like that we'll see how it
goes over the next few days uh but yeah
so again hope you guys have a good
evening have a good day tomorrow and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good night